Okay good afternoon.
Welcome everybody at today were
having an assembly.
It's an official assembly budget
subcommittee subcommittee number
two on education finance.
On the higher education in
California specifically looking
at the campus --
Specific a case study here UC
Santa Barbara this is being
televised through our assembly --
Web portal on the cal channel so
people may be watching across --
California so it's great to be
here today.
In a sunny Santa Barbara it's
raining.
And cold up in a Sacramento high
I know we appreciate Randy it's
gonna rain here in a couple days
so.
I've had a busy morning here at
that's Santa Barbara so far want.
To make cancer yet --
Walk on campus I will no chance
with.
Already.
Death thirteen dot focusing on
higher in general but
specifically looking at that the
UC and UC Santa Barbara and of
course.
I'm excited here to be joined by
my assembly member Monique Limon
who represents --
Of course Santa Barbara the
state assembly --
Also --
Services me on the budget
subcommittee overseeing --
Education funding and hired can
you see funding.
And of course is co hosting this
a hearing with me today and I
think we're gonna be joined
little bit by and by at by
senator Jackson.
And so again one of the think
the the faculty and students for
attending this hearing for
welcoming us --
You know it's important for us --
To to get out throughout
California to see from the
campus perspective what's going
on and so --
Of course we have tenure yes use
and about a hundred community
college campuses so it's
important for us to get out of
the capitol grounds those boring
commuting rooms. To see things
first hand to talk to students
and faculty to see --
Some research professionals and
see things --
First hand and you know the UC
in the state of California are
of course a a partnership.
Supporting the UC operations
that it hasn't been easy since
the Great Recession hit.
High as you know but I we have
been a bit on the rebound as we
know in the last few years we
increase funding by about a
billion dollars since.
Twenty twelve twenty thirteen at
welcome Senate Jackson.
And we of course have greatly
increased a financial aid money
as well cal grant program.
We're really excited about
serving more California students
you know when.
When -- I
know we talk nitty gritty about
things and faculty but when I go
to my trader Joe's.
Soccer field or when
Assemblymembers Lee moaned
talked people well they all want
to talk about their kids their
neighbors and getting access to
the world class university of
California system so --
Certainly with a please that we
increase enrollment by fifteen
thousand slots for California
students.
In the last --
Five years and I know UC Santa
Barbara has had a piece of that --
Seen the steady growth of an AB
21% and and and increase estate
planning in the last five years
have seen.
Certainly --
Help with enrollment growth we
know it's the it's a partnership
again with the we've had.
To look at the three issues
state funding.
Money from from non resident
students throughout California
has been sure we have this is to
find the system.
We also know that higher
education more and more.
In today's --
You know global economy is the
neat you know in order to get a
good paying job.
Today and tomorrow we need more
graduates more people a
certificate said you see is a
piece of the puzzle and not only --
Having --
Increase enrollment but having
graduate within four years.
And I know that --
You see is is that UC Santa
Barbara I was told earlier it's
three point nine years the
average time for graduation here.
That seems like some type of
that type of so you want. To get
to that a bit later but asked by
that and we need to focus on
that statewide as well --
We know there are certainly some
needs --
Sauce some facilities here the
old.
Science buildings which is --
Need a rehab --
You know I think that --
One the side --
So interpreting America looking
forward.
To pushing Florida capital --
Bonds for higher education of
the past few years we've had
that solely on the UC system we
take in order. To to meet --
And Roman growth and to make
sure it's a top notch education
system that they use is that
system having.
Facilities bond the ballot makes
sense --
With that --
I know what we're going to have
a great opportunity to get done
the weeds talk about some issues
and I wanted --
To invites --
Salen member León and senator
Jackson to say a few words the
beginning as well thank you.
Thank you chair at I appreciate
you being here and and and
having this meeting here at as a
member of the committee.
I was very excited to and when
our chair decided that he wanted
to visit you see SB because he
had not yet this is your first
is that right.
UCSB.
Please enter at to my heart.
And the chair is.
Can testify how all.
It's working at UCSB both with
students but also as a staff
member here --
And how that really does become
part of that the deliberation
process it becomes part of the
conversations we have --
And I appreciated --
Assembly member --
MCAT McCarty is approach as well
as assembly member teams
approach [inaudible]
Including in and to continue to
support premier institutions --
But also to find at a pathway
for our students I had to be
part of that premier institution
I think as assembly member
McCarty has said.
At a very common question you
get and not always in the
hearing raining meeting is.
And and I don't have I mean we
have the director of admissions
here so I don't need to even
tell her --
How often she must get the
question is will my son or
daughter didn't get and how do
they get in to you see?
And that reality --
Doesn't state to add admissions
office it really becomes a
reality elected officials as
well.
And we were regularly hearing
that -- But
I I remind folks that the the
reason is because this is a
really great.
Product that we're offering
right it's a really great deal
it's a really great experience
it's a really great education.
And if it wasn't the case then
we wouldn't have people in the
public regularly asking us about
a pathway to get to the UC and
to earn a degree from the UC.
And that's what it comes down to
that we are offering --
Something in California --
That -- All
around the world want to be part
of at so it's exciting at to be
here to hear to get an update --
About where you see SB that and
not just in terms of numbers but
in terms of also directives on
where.
You see SB sees itself going --
I think it's an important
conversation I know at having
worked for the UC sometimes a
certain UC's get --
A lot more of our law of the
kind of the talk and then other
you season so I remind folks
that -- Our
system is a system and certainly
the needs for one you see may
not be replicated at other UC's
and the situation is different --
I've seen how hard you see SB
has tried --
Really been active in not just
retirement but in the enrollment
looking like California --
I I can't even speak enough to
the support services that we
provide for students on campus
and so that is all --
Very important part of the
larger equation --
For us in the state legislature
so I think you all for being
here thank you and to the chair
for hosting this at hearing here.
Think.
Center Jackson yes thank you
arches briefly I want to thank
you for including me in this --
Vent -- This
is this is our university we do
take a very proprietary.
Interest in and the Trancers
here the chance or is.
Is the word ubiquitous or on the
present --
Not necessarily omnipotent but
on the present --
And has done a great job says
the faculty and the student body
and in making UCSB one of the
finest public institutions in
the country.
And I'm honored to serve on the
Senate --
Budget sub one which is the
education subcommittee so I get
a lot of love from the
university usually around budget
time -- But
I give a lot of love I I am.
So honored to to be the senator
representing this area and this
university and not just because
my husband has been the voice of
the gotcha women's basketball --
The public address announcer for
twenty five years mind you --
So we feel as though we are
clearly family but the the
education that comes out of this.
Institution the tremendous --
Public and the community --
Interaction of the university
provides not just in education
for students but a a cultural
advantage to the entire --
Santa Barbara community which I
am particularly appreciative of
and someone who's enjoyed --
It lectures --
Insuring a breaking bread with
professors and learning about
things that I never imagined in
my wildest dreams would to would
rise to the for but which
actually do have an impact on
the future.
Of our state I'm also honored to
serve as the convener of the you
see legislative round table --
And the work that's being done
here the research is being done
at the university Californian
particular ECS be.
This extraordinary and I think
is a guide post for the future.
So.
There are so many wonderful
things that are coming out of
the UC and UCSD and at the same
time of course there's always an
opportunity to learn to improve
to identify things that we may
not have --
Been is --
Is clear about and and things
that we can do always to improve.
To be part of this to hear what
some of those concerns are --
The good things that have been
going on and what we can do
going forward to make it an even
better experience for students
or faculty.
Are in the community at large
thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you out with that we will
begin our hearing when to bring
up but chancellor gang.
To officially welcome S. once
again and give an overview of
today's hearing and then of
course we're going to hear.
From different channels relate
to budget facilities capital and
then a panel of Roman outcome
student services.
And then finally --
Should have sometimes had this
first but the student
perspective so the student
perspective as well as faculty.
So chancellor.
Good afternoon --
Chairman McCarty assembly member
of the moon and the senators
Jackson --
We are and and the whole on a
guest we are absolutely honor
there.
Is to to welcome you to all
campus and we are grateful for
the opportunity to share with
you.
Some of San Santa Barbara such
shipments and the contributions.
We also look forward to
discussing is one of the top
public research university in
California and in the nation.
With a history dating back more
than one hundred twenty five
years.
Our campus has close ties to the
history prosperity and the
vitality of Santa Barbara county
as well as to battle for
neighboring Ventura and the San
Luis Obispo counties.
Establishes a manual training
school in.
Eighteen ninety one and is
subsequently becoming the Santa
Barbara state teachers college
which provide educate towards
for area.
UC Santa Barbara became part of
the university of California
system in.
Nineteen forty four the today in
teaching research and the
community service UC Santa
Barbara has flourished into a
feminine research university
whose tremendous --
Impacts benefitted not only the
local region but also California
or nation and the world of
beyond.
In September.
US news World and World Report
ranked of more than eighteen
hundred universities in the
country.
A multiple public universities
UC Santa Barbara is not
[inaudible]
Five also.
In the graduation rate.
Of fact this year in all one
number.
Five according to a New York
times ranking of the top
colleges most committed to
economic diverse California
state institution committed to
academic excellence diversity
inclusion.
Accessibility and affordability.
In two thousand eighteen would
receive nearly one hundred and
the ten thousand applications.
Ninety two thousand for first
year students and eighteen
thousand four transfers.
When I became chance in?
Nineteen ninety four the number
of freshman applications was
seventeen thousands.
And this.
Sixty so the number has
increased by 6100%.
Was full we will come
approximate fit fifty one
hundred freshmen and a twenty
five hundred transfers to our
campus.
This year.
I am proud to say that we in
rolled the highest number of
California students in the
history of all campus.
Including representation from
one hundred California community
colleges --
Intro class has in every GPA of
four point.
One two and is highly diverse
with 30% under represented
minorities and a 41% first
generation college students.
Well one of sixty two members
still push teachers association
of American universities we
called a U..
And of member to be federally
recognized as a Hispanic serving
institution in.
Two thousand fifteen you have
since had admitted.
Had a second H. SI so both are
you see talk about involvement
in more detail but it
achievement of H. S. I was the
result of a more than two or
three decades long.
Strategy off I'll reach Marmaris
early education programs to get
it at a K. through twelve
students in the state of
California and creating a
supporting campus community for
students.
Including hiring diverse faculty
and the staff.
I myself all with my wife dearly
and our faculty and alumni and
staff teams have reached.
Out annually to California high
school graduates with diverse
city.
Wild paid at the nearly one
hundred thirty regional
receptions over two decades.
As the double demographics of
our student body have changed we
have work to to develop
innovative ways to serve our
students through programming and
initiative such as transfer
student center.
The promise scholarship program --
The center --
Cold -- The
new doors to accelerating
success.
Daniel for undergraduate
education job stop pull and the
colleague Linda and live caster
will be sharing information
about --
Student outcomes.
And then they will also of this.
Whole food security efforts.
Which will be discussed in more
detail by also she by chance for
enrollment Mike Miller --
We always a great deal of thanks
to assembly member.
Monique Limon for all of her
efforts and the contributions
for campus community and the for
her.
Continue to support.
SL --
Representative in the state
assembly --
I also --
One of like to think senator
Jackson for her decades of
support and the contributions.
Of for example a doing a Thomas
fire in the mud slide we Senate
Jackson --
And I we tool with the
disastrous area.
And the we also receive --
I went Sacramento we also
received help from --
Both assembly member the mole
and a centers Jackson during the
time of all the needs.
We owe a great we of hold
distinguished faculty contains a
mall -- A
greatest asset six oh five could
Santa Barbara Limón also one in
the will price in in Dallas this
last year by time.
Educate in London right to seven
hundred fifty diversity is
worldwide for producing Nobel
laureates in this century and UC
Santa Barbara ranks number.
Nine we continue to focus on
improving the diverse city awful
faculty by brought me old rules
and the creating programs and
opportunities that attracted a
highly talented researchers and
educate towards we seek to bring
to recall law students.
Voted the best place to work for
the second year in a row by
readers of the Santa Barbara
independent we are the largest
employer employers in Santa
Barbara county.
And a surface in economic engine
for the central coast --
Campus patents ninety new
inventions and the spins off
half a dozen new start up
companies each year most of
which remain in the Santa
Barbara area.
And in California thereby
contributing to the local and
the state economy.
As portable X. us support.
For entrepreneurship we create --
Graham step provide a business
support for local companies
among them a lot California
Mandel's.
Systems institutes.
Innovation workplace the newly
opened the Wilcox new venture
incubator ended the goal lead to
interpret Norrell magnet program.
I would like to thank all
legislator worse for AB twenty
six sixty four which has helped
the fund some of these
facilities for innovation and
entrepreneurship.
You may be interested in knowing
that Forbes magazine names UC
Santa Barbara among America's
most entrepreneurial
universities number twenty
overall and number five among
public universities.
All of the programs that benefit
all students --
Region and of the state have
been successful due to the
steady and sustained support
from this.
And we all grateful to you.
State supported currently makes
up 20% over campus budget we
need to address the needs of our
growing Ste in body as we
increase the number of
California students.
Will require more classrooms
Berman is. Forty and the staff
we also need to continue to
produce.
In a few impact is in the
economic engine off the state.
I a also wonders thank assembly
member chairman the recorded but
they we went to see a a room off.
Triple room office stoop in a
student dormitory.
We understand it is all
responsibility as a state
institution to be focused on
increasing other revenue sources
we have.
The greater importance all
racing philanthropic support
from alumni and friends these
efforts have been rewarded with
a significant increases in
recent years.
Illustrating that others share
all commitment to to all the to
cation --
Mission.
In addition we continue to
increase the number of research
grants from the federal.
Government and the from coal
incentive foundations to help
fund --
Activities these.
Critical role in supporting --
Educational efforts finally we
all exploring a new project with
a third of the vendor related to
providing workforce housing on
campus.
That we anticipate what address
housing costs to reduce the
traffic in the region in the
benefit the environment.
However the continues support
from.
Your committee and the
colleagues and go having all
campus in university California
system remain not only the best
public universities in the
country but also feeling the
economic engine of the state and
providing the best education. To
the citizens of the state of
California --
Assist.
On the financial health of all
campus and the challenges we
cover in the face including the
issues of deferred maintenance.
Again we want to welcome you to
all campus and look forward to
the opportunity to to share the
stories of UC Santa Barbara bush
many accomplishments into some
awful challenges.
Thank you thank you.
Okay thank you for that starting
soft.
Can you hear me.
My god great --
Classes.
I thank you to chairman of the
sec.
Bowman and Jackson.
My name is James and I and it's
in recent.
Who services the executive
director of budget and planning?
Of the division of finance and
resource management encompasses
the budget office business and
financial services.
I didn't advisory services
procurement institutional
research real estate faculty and
staff housing and capital and
environmental planning.
Your packet you have received --
Provides an overview of are
campus budget as well as recent
history of our revenue and
expense trends.
As noted our budget is been
relatively stable over the last
five years.
We are reliant on student
tuition and fees and state
appropriations for the majority
of our revenues.
With student tuition and fees
comprising thirty per se.
Appropriations at nineteen other
fun sources that make up our
annual budget are largely
restricted or designated find
categories.
Such as gifts contracts and
grants and exhilarating
enterprises.
The vast majority of our
operating expenses nearly 66%
are for employees salaries and
wages and employee benefits.
He's with --
Gentleman Jim benefit impacts
recruitment and retention
efforts Martin and I work with
chancer Yang to stretch our
resources to make ends meet.
We utilize an array of
strategies to match appropriate
resources with campus priorities.
In the fulfillment of our
mission.
Is our offices role to work
closely with our chance wearing
collaborate with campus
constituents on resource
planning. To further enhance the
success of our students and
faculty.
Any new initiatives --
Establishes pilot projects
through the use of one time
funds others are established
over a period of two or three
years whereby we increase the
permanent funds incrementally
resources become available.
And allow the program to just
date with initial one time
seeing funding.
Later this afternoon you will
hear from our colleagues on a
few of these newer initiatives.
We've also utilize revenues
generated from are non resident
tuition to address funding gaps
to somewhat restore programs.
That will reduce during the
budget reductions experienced
earlier this decade.
The challenge of pushing limited
resources for further Google
lean.
Tampa's with since.
These.
Are high rate of student Plamen
allows us to address the
challenging local labor market.
And provides an important source
of income and professional
development for our students.
While we have been a resourceful
and innovative campus many
initiatives in early phase
opportunities are not pursued
due to physical constraints.
The best funding scenario for
our campus is one with
predictable consistent revenue
growth over a period of time.
Your your financial
uncertainties push our campus
into a strategy where and we
protect resources.
Committed to the essential
basics and perhaps miss the
opportunity to make additional
headway in pursuit of excellence.
We are accustomed to addressing
budget budgetary challenges we
are always appreciative of our
partnership with the state of
California.
In securing long term financial
viability we can both say the
funds invested at UC Santa
Barbara bring about positive
impact in the lives of our
students faculty and staff and
for the benefit of our state and
nation.
Perhaps even more importantly
than the annual operating budget
challenges we face our campus is
feeling significant and growing
pressure from limited capital
budget resources.
We do not benefit from the very
financial resources available to
campuses with medical centers.
And have a much greater reliance
on traditional core funds such
as state appropriations and
student fees for our annual
operations.
This means our campus has fewer
resources to draw upon when
seeking funds to construct new
instructional and research
buildings or to address the ever
growing need for deferred
maintenance investment.
Over the past two decades we
have utilized the Garamendi
mechanism. To fund capital
expansion.
As you may know this was a state
program that allowed the campus
to read [inaudible]
In increments the balance
between additional in direct
cost recovery funds and capital
needs.
While we were able to construct
much needed space this further
reduce the amount of flexible
funding needed operate our
campus.
We believe we have leverage this
funding source as far as we can.
Stem pride program such as
physics and engineering are
amongst the more desired
programs for two days you see
applicants.
Our ability to accommodate these
hopeful undergraduates is
impacted by shortage of space.
Are physics program is rated by
the national Research Council
amongst the top five programs in
the nation.
Since two thousand six we've
experienced a 3100% increase in
our undergraduate physics majors
enrollment and this friends not
slowing down.
However we've not seen an
increase in permanent physics
space since.
Nineteen ninety four our campus
undertaken a planning exercise
to program and budget a new
building to address the needs
for additional physics space.
We anticipate the need for a
hundred and twenty five thousand
square foot building.
With the construction costs of
roughly a hundred and sixty
million to address that current
need.
Our campus simply doesn't have
the fiscal resources necessary
to address a facility of that
magnitude.
Our campus also anticipate to
facility of similar size and
construction costs for
engineering program.
A highly ranked engineering
program is also in the in great
demand from undergraduate
applicants and experiences a
similar need for instruction and
respect space.
The likelihood of constructing
new physics engine engineering
space is entirely reliant on
capital funding from the state.
In addition to our focus on
laboratory buildings all over
campus disappointing shooting
including humanities and fine
arts and social sciences.
Are impacted by a shortage of
classroom space.
As our campus a Roman grows our
daily classroom facilities are
challenged to keep up with
today's instructional needs.
The last classroom building on
our that our campus constructed
was completed in.
Nineteen sixty seven we have --
Recently received preliminary
project approval from the UC
regents for new classroom
building to be constructed
utilizing AB ninety four funding.
As combined with campus funds
derived earnings.
This building will provide more
than twenty three hundred new
classroom seats in support of
undergraduate education.
In addition to the pressing need
for major capital investment
we're in the process of
inspecting our facilities and
cataloging or deferred
maintenance backlog as part of
the UC wide initiative.
I present our best estimate of
deferred maintenance for our
state supported facilities is
nearly six hundred million
dollars.
Most of our buildings range up
our range in age from forty
building systems are at the end
of their useful life.
In the past couple of years
we've utilized one time state
funds to address our greatest
points of failure but the
backlog is significant and
growing larger.
Deferred maintenance has also
presented challenges for many of
our lab renovations as we
recruit new faculty.
Many of our newly recruited
faculty need specialized
laboratory instruction spaces
and these sorts of reap
renovations can trigger building
like system replacement.
And associated CO complaints
upgrades.
Issue said to be such as he is
make the process of factly
recruitment even more difficult.
In summary we wish to thank you
for the opportunity to highlight
some of the challenges we face
here at UCSB --
We hope this free presentations
been informative.
And Martin and I are happy to
answer any questions you may
have for us.
But that hasn't for to have one
okay gotcha I do have been times
interview questions sure --
As I as I noted earlier Ripper
very aware of the capital
conversations and because I told
them earlier.
Whenever we go on a tour of a
college campus we always go and
see the crime the science lab.
Whether it's a community college
who UC or CSU so we know that to
AB we invested.
In the we used to have in the
nineties and two thousands and
injects remembered.
Now that the bonds on the ballot
had been they they K.. Fourteen
months and I think we should go
back through the cake threes
three sixteen bonds to focus
that for UC and CSU.
So that being said --
How much is currently being
diverted from your friend for
example UC Santa Barbara lot me?
To to capital of this all these
which otherwise could go --
To campus needs.
Student services expanding
enrollment you know maybe
painting as a picture.
Okay -- If
if even a back of the envelope
if yeah that that's probably the
best I'm going to be able to do
for you --
So are --
Our overall expenditure on
deferred maintenance on a year
to year basis is about four
point five million dollars if
you set aside on in permanent
funding.
And in addition to that if we
have one time funding we
increase that those are dollars
that we have at the state park
sorry at the university that we
would have.
Directed elsewhere on the campus
if we weren't committing those
to deferred maintenance programs.
I think the the other thing.
And and I've just got to give
you kind of back of the envelope
estimates on that there's you
know it at least.
Somewhere in the nay lab
renovations and facility
renovations were utilizing
indirect cost recovery from
federal grants and we're taking
those dollars.
In turning around and investing
them in renovation lab
renovation programs that we work
spent money on those laps we
probably with.
Using for more last --
Off the top.
Would be the data associated
with Garamendi mechanism.
And so that that was a choice
the campus made where.
We were able to take money that
would have otherwise been used
for instructional purposes and
committed to pay down --
And we have five buildings I
think that our Garamendi funded
that and the largest one of
which is --
Bioengineering building and they
believe the Garamendi component
of that was about a forty five
million dollar.
Obligation so the annual --
Interest on all of those
buildings combines probably in
the neighborhood of seven to
eight million would be my guess
[inaudible]
Longer face [inaudible]
The without.
A I TP physics yet longer but
that will that --
Entropy yeah we did receive
philanthropy yeah that's a
should know that of course --
We had a donor who provided --
The donor developed project to
provide the residents for
visitors of our Cavalli
institute of theoretical physics
up Charlie Munger.
Provided that and that was a
sixty five million dollar
building that he bill for us we
didn't have to take something
like that on so.
If they basically tell you what
you're going to bill yeah yeah I
mean it's I don't say no but I
mean it's that there's not a
whole lot of you know given take
their yeah certainly --
Donor interest in a project can
have varying levels of control
but it one one which their
funding the entire thing if it
is a more at the toners.
Discretion certainly in
consultation with the campus but
yeah.
Noticed my brother relationship
with Santa Barbara.
But he does his aye grandson was
a student there you go yeah good
kid thing to have enough said
he's been actively engage with
our campus yeah --
And those kinds of gifts come
kind of once in a lifetime yes
so.
Yeah they are they are very
unique we don't see Gipson of
that magnitude very frequently
he if I may you you didn't
mention the housing problem --
Which is a significant problem
this was the last university
built within the coastal zone --
And as a result building within
it is has been.
I'd a challenge and and frankly
if I'm not mistaken quite
expensive yeah --
With it I don't I hope I'm not
jumping ahead but it seemed like
a logical question ask.
Given the fact that you saw a
room with three in a room that
probably should have been for
one and a half dissipating.
Resolving that housing problem
going forward --
There was a mention by the
chancellor which I thought.
I did want.
To get a little more information
about this workforce housing on
campus with a third party vendor.
Could you perhaps sure I'd be
happy to share a little bit and
then also the whole housing
issue we don't have enough
housing here.
And UCSB housing and I love this
state is legendary.
I won't say overall helpful but
legendary over the course years
were you'll have eight or nine
students in a house on what is
the the the you know.
I forget the street at the
moment I don't know what I am
thinking del playa fits a two or
three bedroom so they create
bunk housing in the living room
and god only knows what else
they're very resourceful.
But there just isn't enough
housing yes that and then this
third party short.
Of when you start with a third
party project --
Because that's one we're working
on right now I think I can work
with just one Mike here.
Like the stereo effect up --
So Ocean road is a project our
campus --
Started working on in two
thousand six in the intent there
is for us to build --
A major housing development that
would be mixed use housing so
some retail or campus serving
space on the first floor and
residential above --
Intended to be entirely for
faculty and staff.
At UCSB opponent would be a for
sale and a component would be
rental housing.
And this was really our campuses
attempt to address workforce
housing.
On our campus and so what's
envisioned is over a project
that would --
Delivers somewhere in the
neighborhood of five hundred and
forty residential units and that
would be combinations of one two
three and four bedroom units --
Associated parking it's which is
currently the border of on the
campus with file best I think
when you walk to ID last night
process.
It's a it's a wide road we're
going to narrow the road and
there is a significant amount of
campus land running.
Along the north south fine --
Of the border of Isla Vista and
that would all be developed to
be faculty and staff housing.
We're looking to do that what
the third party developer.
And so the dentist to find --
Development --
Agency that would come in.
And would enter into a long term
ground lease with the university
develop that housing manage the
rental component and sell the
for sale component of the
housing.
The faculty and staff.
We think --
You know some of the the major
benefits of that are obviously
bringing.
Up our campus population closer
to the campus so folks who were
commuting hours would have the
opportunity to walk to work --
It we also think that.
I love this the which is you
know currently X. during the
summer and during the holiday
season --
And then bringing in a different
age population that would
probably spur different sorts of
businesses and really help make
sure.
That I love this the business
district and I think that that's
it's an excellent opportunity.
For I love this set and for the
university of to get a great
example of a convergence.
I think --
That process we are starting the
early planning phase of that and
we would intend to use a request
for proposal process public
process. To identify the
developers and we think that'll
happen at the beginning of this
coming year.
And so sometime in twenty
nineteen will be out on the
streets looking for the
development partner.
And hopefully make that move
board it was included in our
party P..
So it has its preliminary
approval from the coast mission
although it will need of project
specific approval --
As the student housing we have --
An agreement with the local
community.
With our long range development
plan that we would build five
thousand beds to address our
increasing enrollment through
the year twenty twenty five we
built about fifteen minutes not
read.
New bands that do that yes
correct net new beds is the term
I think we use and yeah.
That is --
Intended --
To to address all of our
enrollment agreement during that
time and so.
We've.
As we opened a San Joaquin which
was a thousand new balance in
apartments around ascetic
Catalina the tower resonances
malls --
We're currently in the planning
phase for the next phases of
student housing --
And we're considering at like a
variety of options of what the
the best way to go --
Part LRT Pete envisioned
redeveloping existing housing
sites.
And so going into what is
currently stork apartments --
Senate as apartments in our west
apartment as well as some of the
Channel Islands residents also
we toured today. To redevelop
those areas and increase the
density and build additional.
Housing [inaudible]
The number [inaudible] Two I
think a difficult environment
for young people.
Living three people to a room --
That's really not intended for
more than --
Two and other things of that
sort.
The fact that you're going to
increase the density concerns me
a little bit --
I'm told some of this can create.
Health issues.
Mental health issues.
I mean I I'm too old to envision
being back in college and having
to share a room with anybody --
Hard enough sharing a house with
but I think this is.
This is a concern I I can I
don't know if it's within the
scope of the state's national.
City I thought you meant multi
story or you're not talking
about within all all the people
in it in an individualized could
not not more people sharing
bedrooms ideally.
We would be de chanting those
students that are in the in
three person rooms.
Into two rooms yeah that would
that would ultimately be the
call but that being said putting
is the to rather than three are
you actually increasing
availability of housing or just
making it more livable --
We would be increasing the
availability okay yeah that is
the intent.
Well I'm glad to hear that that
that I was misunderstanding I
just think.
We've got to take into account
human behavior and trying to
crunch a whole bunch of people
into a room is.
Is not good. For for one so I
think mental and physical health.
Care thank you you know what I
had some budget questions but
let's take that stick on housing
from it because because frankly
this is an issue.
Not Santa Barbara you see why
see is you wide it.
There are no easy --
Solutions to it and so we're
trying to to think out outside
the box --
You know one thing that I I I've
been seeing across California
and even right in my district.
By.
They get landers under utilized
strip mall across the street or
few.
More than a mile away.
And you know tearing it down and
build a multi family housing
there because universities you
know.
We hear a lot about housing
plans to meet with you know
present the poll thành I'll
talk about.
But that's not your bread and
butter and you know that you
bred better is educating
students and two buildings in
hand facilities and that's hard
not in and of itself.
Yep but you know doing massive
housing development just it's
it's it's it's it's not.
On my* so.
No here you have third straight --
You know.
Did you in simplicity.
My understanding is.
Here's all the title more land
outside of the university so
that's Mike my first things kind
of what's happening on the
outside you know.
If you start with that sure well
it you know it's an interesting
environment for us here so when
we went forward with our long
range development plan in --
Two thousand ten the chancellor
encouraged us to get out and
meet with the representatives of
the county of Santa Barbara
Santa Barbara and city a leader.
And actually negotiate the terms
for whatever development would
look like and what were the
conditions that.
That they would find acceptable
as we move forward so weak we
engaged in a multi month process --
With those folks and one of the
conditions they felt very
strongly was that we had to
absorb a 100% of our enrollment
growth on existing campus land.
And they did not want us to buy.
Any land from either Kalita or
the I love this to and develop
not because it was a concern
about coming off the tax rolls.
And so there was a real emphasis
for us to build and develop on
our existing land and that terms
we agreed.
To wear that any housing bills --
I think there's some things we
probably didn't understand at
that time week we didn't quite
understand what the make up of I
love this to was --
We thought it was just UCSB
students and community and I
think there's a much larger
population in Isla Vista and as
we build housing.
I live as the cap back feeling
very quickly --
The city of galena has has --
Approved and constructed a
significant amount of
residential space.
Both for sale and rental space
and their intent and desire is
they would rather that be. For
nine students and so what they
they've kind of looked at is is
this is for good leaders growth
and they don't want to see you
see espys growth.
Consuming that housing and so
there hasn't been a mindset of
saying cam the community.
Bill the housing for the
university and and we stick to
just doing university there was
really a push for us.
To be self sufficient in that
regard.
I think as we looking go forward
we have to consider options --
When we did the long range
development plan there was not a
lot of third party development
in the UC system?
And now it's you know it's it's
rampant it's change that we
probably need to go back to the
city and county and talk through.
You have something that
[inaudible]
About your that's okay
chancellor but when they had
something but back to the the
overall housing crunch --
It's it's it's really to Paul
that the impacts it's one is
that just the debt load if you
have could that debt load for
the average you see your seats
you graduate.
Between twenty and thirty
granted it's not tuition you
know.
Because two thirds of your
students here other kids.
Cal grant held or enter the you
know the UC coal or middle class
scholarship to the paying
minimal tuition and housing.
And then of course --
You know to look at but access
if we had more housing that you
would be less pressure the long
redevelopment plan you can
stretch out of certain more.
Californians and more than
people that are hit me up at
trader Joe's about how.
Their kids want to be a Galgiani
even from Santa Barbara
[inaudible]
So -- What
could this what could we're
talking all about problems here
double I I know we talked about
this? One for college students.
I have to admit I haven't
thought about.
It you know forever housing is
being considered something that
was a self supporting --
Enterprise in so it was never
eligible for state support.
And so --
You know probably it would be
and the incentives for
developers and and spring the
development community.
I think would be an area where
the state could play a and is
there anything I entitled issues
because certainly.
If you went bottom vacant lot.
You know.
Austrian Isla this that now for
example you have to go through
that.
Santa Barbara county planning
department all that but if you
have it on you see land you go
through your own.
Houses is rare been thoughts as
far as if it's university
project within a certain area
and any ideas about entitlement.
And development.
Well that's that's probably one
of the great advantages
university house is being its
own.
You know that certainly is
something that helps.
But again we are in a situation
where our local community didn't
want us to expand our physical
footprint and to the neighboring
communities and so.
You know it's it's it probably
is -- The
better poll of us buying
property elsewhere is the impact
on property tax.
I think that that's the thing
that's about that would be
difficult for the county if we
come in and we buy something and
take it off the tax rolls --
If we're keeping on the tax
rolls that puts a challenge on
the affordability and so there's
a little bit of a vicious circle --
And in that regard.
So if you if Santa Barbara
bought land just across the
street Derek and I love this
stuff.
Would you take can you entitle
it through the UC process yes
yeah.
Okay yeah.
Yeah so when we buy it if it
comes region's land we entitled
it through the UC process.
Now we're still in the coastal
zone.
So we still have to go through
the coastal --
Commission for any sort of
approval of the developing an
outside of the coastal zone then
it would solely be at the
region's for entitlement.
It is sort of the dilemma
[inaudible]
It's not.
You can do.
We are clear and I think get
UCLA instead of are we don't
have adequate housing for our
students.
So it took a chicken and egg
problem.
And I would suspect that not
only are there some fiscal
issues but I think in terms of
land use and so forth.
I'm not sure go leaders excited
about having more students and
have this design incorporated
night there are those issues and
you know it really is a bit of a
dilemma but it does add to the
cost of students coming to
school when they have got --
To pay exorbitant amounts of
money for very little in the way
of a place to live and I I don't
know if you see SB has a problem
but I keep hearing about
different schools where some of
our students are living in their
cars and and couch surfing and
that's just.
No way to you can't study you
know center Jackson.
You.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Accommodating the student for
the housing is is only one of
the most important thing --
Actually --
Because of the increasing and in
state students we want
accommodate more California
students.
So we we need more.
Most pressing needs other more
classrooms teaching.
Learning facilities and also
increased the number of staff to
take care of them --
The increasing number Offa
faculty members to give them
better teaching an accommodation
and then the building the
facilities for a comedy they
living --
Environment it is one of the
very important thing if the
state can help us in the other
areas like teaching faculty and
all that I think university when
we do well we can also seek from
anthropic support to help us.
With -- With
with the dormitories we're still
working on that so their own
these old rule problems.
And if we campaña accommodating
more students I think we can
ease that the niece and I have a
stock which is one of five all
current effort as well.
Because I'm gonna go back to the
budget --
And I appreciate the
conversation about housing I
think it historically number
sessions about housing in Santa
Barbara county --
Have been difficult.
Whether we look at that lends
from -- From
the student perspective or just
from residents perspective --
And I think that that will
continue --
Related to the budget it was
great to hear and to at you know
things are going well now.
And in the state legislature
we've also had conversations
about what the future of
California's budget looks like.
And one of the questions I know
that at some of the folks that
have followed that the hearings
at the state level have heard me
ask that I want to ask locally
is.
What are we doing to prepare for
the next recession --
As a campus --
And some predict sooner rather
than later and how are we
preparing so that we don't see --
Some of the elements that we've
seen in past recessions that
results in you know I mean if
you look at the history that's
when tuition has gone the
highest rate in the period of
recessions --
And so forth and that's also a
very difficult time but what is
the campus doing now to think
about that.
Yeah I would say.
That if you know.
Our role Martin and I share the
role of really being careful
stewards of our funds.
And so as we work on our Alex is
a fun. One the permanent fund
and hear we permanent commitment
and that.
Also is is can extrapolate to a
staff member or faculty member
and so it's really got to do
with --
Hiring people so the more the
more are --
We would add to our work force
the more we'd have a an ongoing
obligation that would be
severely impacted in the budget
cuts.
And so I think it's a campus
we've been frugal about our
staffing and we've been --
We we've been a campus that
looks at how can we do more with
less.
And have focused on that we are --
In a in a period where we're
really looking at our the
funding gaps that started in two
thousand eight and how we
address those I think an
important dialogue we're gonna
be having on our campus in the
next couple of years is.
Your what programs are really
important to continue --
What programs maybe shouldn't
continue and that's never an
easy conversation to have that's
something that can help
safeguard us but it's really
taking a look at where where are
permanent obligations and where
are our --
Less permanent obligations in
trying to understand how we
balance that I think we ban --
We've been encouraging.
Folks -- To
to look at their funds it and
occasionally we have --
Some give funds where we really
encourage folks to put those
into funds functioning as
announcements where they
generate some interest revenue.
During the period with which
they aren't spent so sometimes
will receive some source of
funding.
It's intended to be spent over a
seven to ten year period and we
know that spending periods
coming a little later.
And so we're talking about
investing that money right now
so it yields some interest
return and that the mean time --
We're trying whatever we can to
make ourselves a little bit more
recession proof.
I think that --
The budget cuts weeks uber
really difficult for our campus
and we've struggle to get our
faculty FTP back up to the
levels they work.
In two thousand seven eight and
where we're barely there.
And so -- I
would say we certainly haven't
gone and over spent at present
and so that that will in another
itself protect us a bit --
But I think looking at the
watchful answer P. and really
growing outside of our campus
has been an important part
wherever we can.
Look at something is creating
revenue is equally important
quite frankly we seen a greater
sharing of campus obligations.
And financial obligations with
auxiliaries on our campus where
we've we've taken the entities
that are revenue generating and
ask them to carry more of the
work of the love so.
Some of those strategies have
been helping us as well just.
The most important strategy up
off all what we talk about is
tenth.
We have gone through several
recessions are myself going
through it.
But I think one of the most
important principle is that.
We should have developed the
principles that that.
No matter what we do.
We must not a come.
So with these two large
principles then we make the
budget cut and trim and also.
We we do it very carefully --
With all what it Chuck just
mention about --
The waste to to to to to if it
comes to a recession.
But we will I think education.
Quality.
And diversity of the most
important principle that.
We must not compromise.
Just to add --
To what Chuck was saying in
terms of tactics so are
permanent budget has been
growing there's been enrollment
growth instead of having the the
permanent budget grow exactly
with enrollment we've tried to
be a little more conservative
with that and maybe like a year
or two what if and Roman.
Pope pulled back but what if
there were other pressures so
that's the specific tactic we've
done with various fund sources --
Ticket that cushion at Chuck
described.
I see here on the the non
residents enrollment that of
course has been a hot issue in
the state legislature last
year's and up assembly pushed
very hard couple years ago the
region's adopted.
Happen in this faster in the
budget the Senate actually adopt
a language trying to go. To
lower lower numbers and so
that's you know would be nice as
well.
And and so he for a lot of the
campus is it's it's made a huge
chunk of the revenue to to
basically you know keep it going.
And so sub campuses like.
LA in Brooklyn San Diego they
have you know more.
More money per student and so
there.
Academic quality you could argue
is little bit different than at
number Saturday riverside which
had some some of the lower lower
number so looks like Santa
Barbara's kind of in the middle
of the season but you have.
Gone up the last five years from
from five two to sixteen and so
I assume that's been a big chunk.
Of on my revenue and some some --
Some of the a like this but
they're able to utilize their
Medical.
Center revenue to help make a go
of it so.
In mice my district I have UC
Davis.
I represent not the campus that
that the Medical Center which is
a huge part of the UC Davis
enterprise in LA --
San Diego of course and so --
Maybe you can paint a picture of
Santa Barbara how you're able.
To how it impacts the you know
the average experience for your
undergraduate students.
With not having the Medical
Center and what you've been able
to wear the monies go from the
increase revenue --
For international and non and
out of state students and
conversely if you didn't have
that what it would look like for
instance.
Yakin talk about the non
resident part for yeah so I
don't we have a four hundred
twenty two million dollars as of
budget to sure from student
tuition and fees.
And a hundred and thirteen
million of that is the non
resident students.
Border directly yet 27% of that.
And and as you mentioned that's
grown over the last --
In a address the other.
Well I would just say that the
you know it has become an
important source of revenue for
the campus it's a what I would
call perhaps more flexible form
of revenue and so --
It's something that we've
utilized --
We've covered some dead expenses
with that we certainly have been
dedicating those dollars towards
a deferred maintenance program
we mentioned --
There been a number of of
programs around student success
some of the program's you'll
hear about today --
We've also been making
investments is sustainability
with some of those dollars --
And that's been a really
important one for us because it
has a kind of a two for a fact
it's meeting our goals as a
campus for sustainability.
But it's also managed to corral
all our utilities expenses and
it's a bit over that period of
time.
But our energy use has not.
And so that's from some of those
investments coming that way --
I would just say in principle
and in the end. For me
philosophically as I look at non
resident tuition.
It's not the most comfortable
source of revenue for me as a
manager on the campus because it
it puts us.
Reliant on the economy of other
countries and as long as those
economies are generating
[inaudible]
Revenue.
And you know they're productive
a nothing.
Being their students.
Does make me worry when we have
a potentially in a
disproportionate amount of what
we're counting on is permanent
budget coming from --
Other nations and whatever their
economic policies are so.
There's volatility associated
with that I don't think it is a
you know something that should
be a long term strategy to say
keep growing that in river and
in support of other funds going
away right now are.
Total.
Non resident rather revenues
equal to about 50% of our state
support.
So it it it is a significant
chunk of money --
On the campus that we are
reliant on but it it does worry
me.
So that the policy that the
region's adopted.
Now two years ago.
Have had a cap of no more than
18% for those other.
Campuses that were already about
twenty correct so that means
that.
Right now.
Santa Barbara here at 16% yeah
non resident and you could.
Legally go up to eighteen right
yes is that the plan.
I don't know I think we've you
know we we have not made such a
plan nobody you know I have to
say although state is not just
in our nine out of standing many
out of California and other
forty nine states still counts.
Yeah yeah.
Is there a huge.
Demand you have way more
applications for non resident.
Than you do slots available I
would have to have --
Or director admissions answer
that I believe that is the
ACLU's you see why I know that
yeah even even when we increased.
Non resident we feet there
hasn't even though the whatever
elasticity.
Study with us right hasn't had
much of a drop so in other words
even.
There's a huge demand we could
internationally and other states
nine the non resident tuition
combined with our tuition your
housing expenses and we have you
know there's a policy that
there's no financial aid.
Provided to non residents so
there we were competing with you
know what what may be the cost
of other --
You know prime ivy league
schools into whether we've price
yourself out of that market I
think Lisa can talk about that
when she's up here --
It it -- But
obviously by going from.
In in the last eight years.
You've quadrupled from four to
sixteen so there is a demand
people are there is only about
the Santa Barbara story of
course you could walk out and
see the beautiful ocean.
And and I think probably work
it's out.
The other people or from your
home state or for the country
and so forth about the
experience you're finding and
you see SB certainly --
The the one thing I did want to
bring up though that that you
had mentioned that.
The the language from the Senate
about reducing yeah nonresident
rolling down --
To down 210% of enrollment that
that impact for our campus would
be about forty two million
dollars of what we would can now
call permanent funding.
That's that's almost equivalent
to was for a for UCSB when the
UC experience a very large
budget cuts so it.
Is significant let me ask want
one more question about student
fees and I'm guessing is very
unpopular.
But but sometimes I wonder. For
the student fee increases if we
shouldn't go forth with it in
the first place because it
really boils down.
To upper middle class students
who who are impacted I think I'm
not sure the number here at UC
Santa Barbara finding is that.
Well over half the students.
A new no tuition and all other
cal grant of power is it two
thirds it happens.
It's it's over half I don't know
that number right off the top of
my head we probably have it here
and then.
A few years ago we adopted the
middle class scholarship so now
we go up to find. Two thirds of
tuition for income I think it's
up to now hundred and seventy
thousand dollars roughly better.
For a family of four and so.
You know that's a great.
Who are some of the suits a so?
If it comes down.
To in you when you build your
budgets you're looking for a
minor saying is kind of a three
piece --
Stole yeah non resident money
state monies to get the money
yep and so.
Sometimes I just wonder is it
worth I know that students.
Student fees like the holy --
Third rail --
And I get it but you know for
many many students who come in
and talk about the student fee
increases we ask them like that
they'll pay tuition anyway yeah
because they get financial like
some.
I see some students screaming
back yeah and I I I think that
that is.
Most likely an unpopular idea I
from a from a purely economic
standpoint.
There there is a large segment
of our enrollment that has their
tuition cover into the idea of
raising their tuition.
The return to a component of
that raise tuition insurers that
they in fact this portion of the
population is in paying it --
It'd shifting that expense
burden to the higher income
state not.
That's the economics of it.
The I you know somewhere around
two thousand and eight nine was
when we kind of the path.
Being being equal.
To two I'm in a back then. For
for the for the budget now its
way to where you know the
students are paying 37% and the
state's at nineteen and so that.
That's released swayed quite a
bit and so I think that their
you know there's a there's a
concern about --
Is is -- If
the unit if the state can't
restore funding similar to where
it had been before that pressure
will naturally moved towards.
Tuition.
I would just say for myself when
I came here as was two hundred
forty eight dollars a quarter.
You know it's it it was a long
long time ago and the state was
in a much different style places
well you're depriving it's an
important question because it's
a reality check as as as
literally months that we've
we've had a five year run.
In the economy California budget
like no other in a hundred years
and it's not going to continue.
And it just the laws of
economics are gonna have a
reality check in your future so.
We have to to to weigh those
things out I will note that in
this one thing we always
perspective.
It is that the state increase
has gone down but that student
be revenue keep in mind that a
bunch that state money as well
as a we increased.
Fees ready pay them the counter
in the grant program so read
look as how much money from the
state California checkbooks
going to pay.
For college you may not all be
going. To you see what it goes
the student commission and back
door to see so it's still is
yeah cal grant it's just.
Yeah yeah.
Okay.
Thank you this was --
Helpful.
And again there's there's no
magic so they were looking for
it is just helpful in
understanding the decisions we
make up beard Sacramento.
Impacts of cost [inaudible]
Scott.
Conservative approach to funding
has any impact on your you know
the folks who work here.
And I know that for graduate
students one of the keys to
getting.
Could graduate students is being
able.
To and I know that the
university has had some
challenges because we don't
offer them --
Particularly much and instead of
coming to UCSB they go to the
university of Texas or some
other ungodly place.
And you know it makes it
difficult for us to keep to
sustain that quality.
Of educational experience those
researchers are helpful to the
professors who want to have
those students.
The top in a we want the cream
of the cream here to be.
Our students so it's a it's of a
yin and the Yang here we're not.
By being frugal --
It's sometimes does also cost us
the quality of of student that
we're looking for particularly
in the graduate level so.
I'm mindful of that and I
appreciate the question what are
we doing the next recession hits
big [inaudible]
Refer people.
Thing is that we and so.
Contributed the school I don't
know how much more we can expect
them to do --
Any more longer grandkids we can
real.
Well.
I I will stand silent on that
but there certainly are folks
out there who do appreciate this
great university --
But that we can't rely on that.
For our programs okay thank you
thank you with us today this
panel next we're gonna have a
handle on in Romans outcomes the
student services.
So please come on up. For for
participants
.
Thank you chair McCarty.
Assembly member Monique and
senator Jackson I'm Jeff stop
will associate vice chancellor
for undergraduate education.
With me here is Linda Adler
Kassner faculty director for the
center of innovative teaching
research and learning.
We appreciate the opportunity to
talk with you about UC Santa
Barbara innovative three sixty
degree support for achievement
of our rigorous learning
outcomes.
Would like to thank the
legislature for this
accomplished the number.
Is noted our student body is
also increasingly diverse 30%
identifies under represented
minorities and 41% are first
generation college students.
Also emphasize that we are the
first member of the prestigious
association of American
universities to be certified as
a Hispanic serving institution.
Additionally of note is that 30%
of our students come from
families with an income below
fifty thousand dollars a year.
This matter is for learning.
Family income correlates most
strongly with educational
preparation and achievement. One
consequence is a gap in GPA and
time to completion for some of
the students. To address this
gap we've created innovative
programs to develop a thriving
learners.
We referred to them as three
hundred and sixty degree
programs because they support
learners and faculty.
We know that learning is a two
way street students need to be
prepared to learn from faculty
and faculty need to know how to
best invite students into a
learning process.
After all learning is something
that someone does not something
done to them.
Learning takes practice feedback
from experts and time.
Our programs help students
develop three parts of an
equation that lead to success in
college and beyond.
Disciplinary knowledge skills
for academic and career success.
And senses of themselves as
learners.
Wilshire illustrations a
programs we've created in
conjunction with each piece of
this equation.
Also share with you ways we hope
you can help us advances work.
First or two academic success
centers --
Beyond us or opening new doors
for exhilarating six engine.
And a transfer student center.
Both support entering students
especially first generation and
low income students both opened
in.
Twenty fifteen donde center with
support from a two point five
million dollars H. us I grant
from the US department of
education.
And the transfer student center
with support from one point six
million dollars in special
student success funding from the
UC office of the president.
Provide academic advising
academic mentoring.
Structured opportunities for
students to get to know faculty
and workshops focusing on all
aspects of cops life.
More than.
Six thousand I visited centers.
More than. 140% of the campuses
Waldron elation in fact uses the
TSC regularly.
Under us and the TSC illustrate
the comprehensive support that
you see SB provides for students
to be our institutions rigorous
learning outcomes.
Develop senses of belonging here.
But three hundred and sixty
degree support also extends
beyond students.
We work with back across campus
to develop innovative pedagogies
to make their expertise more
accessible. For instance thirty
nine faculty have participated
in the yearlong seminar
supported by the department of
education title five grant.
They redesigned assignments in
courses to improve student
learning.
By the end of fall quarter
twenty eighteen these thirty
nine faculty will talk more than
thirty eight thousand students.
That is only one example of this
kind of program efforts
contribute to improving students
learning and improving retention
and time to degree.
Through all this work with
faculty and students we have
identified important practices
that contribute to learning
gains.
Will show just two of them.
The first is incorporating
active learning and teaching.
Sir Steve got gallons large
biological anthropology lecture
watch video lectures take online
quizzes and submit questions
about quirk course content in
advance of class meetings.
In class they discuss the
questions with each other and
with professor gallon.
This active learning approach
makes the most of face to face
class time through interaction
and engagement.
Research shows that this
approach contributes
significantly to learning
especially among under
represented low income and first
generation students.
The second is academic mentoring
especially from undergraduate
peers.
Right now eight departments have
such programs which contribute
significantly to learning games.
We are also using technology for
the support.
We collaborate with university
of Michigan on each coach a
technology platform that
provides course specific
coaching written by humans to
support learning and study
strategies tailored for students.
You coach was initiated using
one point seven million dollars
in one time funding we received
from the legislature to support
low income students.
Students from underrepresented
minority groups and students
enrolled and local control
funding formula schools. To
conclude we want to identify two
ways we hope you can support our
three hundred sixty degree
approach.
First the legislature can
provide stable sustain support
for programs that help us close
the achievement gap for all
learners.
The programs we described here
have been supported by stood.
Rents like the one from the
department of education.
And Elsie FF plus funding from
the legislature.
Of these only student success
funding from you see okay as
permanent.
The campus is trying to sustain
funding for these programs and
others like them the support
timely degree and success.
Second you can help us create
As we've noted that everyone has
you see SB is one of the most
beautiful campuses on the
outside but classrooms and labs
as you've noted don't
necessarily match the exterior.
We don't have space for a
booming student population.
Learning spaces are in desperate
need of renovation built at a
time when we knew less about the
importance of active learning
pedagogies for learning games.
The support is critical even as
we plan.
Classroom [inaudible]
And for efforts.
For funding and that is.
The state can help us make a
difference here at UCSB.
And more importantly a
difference for California like
you we believe that all of our
students are learners and
citizens and together we can
build a better future.
Thank you ammo for to any
questions you have.
Elected team --
DJing.
I get a lot.
Of us on our to show one of the
things if I may Mister yes --
Jump in here of one of the
things that we look for in the
legislature and is frequently --
Lacking the some metrics.
So.
How much money have you spent
how many students have you
dressed water the success levels
how are you measuring success?
We're going to put more money in
and help make this permit which
is what I yeah well it's working
graduation rates take time to to
measure we hope to see
improvements in graduation rates --
Particular for the transfer
students --
Is.
That's a real concern for us.
I think that will be important
Telesat I mean if you have a
program that works.
I suspect we're going to want to
implement that elsewhere if it's
the best program out there but
that is I think something that --
Becomes important this is tell
us how how well it's it's a call.
School I'm.
We absolute Kerr with that
assessment Dreamland.
The main areas.
Work and work as the redwood
education. One of the challenges
is that learning games take time
to manifest themselves so if we
implemented.
Intervention.
It could have short term results
can have different kinds of long
term results and so we have data
on some of the short term
results of some of these and we
just decided to a sort of sweet
of kinds of interventions and
program so we have data on some.
Of them.
But twenty fifteen is not long
ago so we need more time so you
measuring.
The students whether that
graduating or not what what if
some of them are at risk of it
is the goals the goal to see
them graduate is the goal to see
them get jobs as a goal to see
them get ago want to get.
Other degrees so made those are
things I think that would be
helpful for us to know what it
is you're measuring right yes
programs are specifically
focused I think and and getting
students to graduate on time
there's a lot of other.
Wonderful thing state.
In the camps is doing in terms
of steering students into
graduate programs when that's
appropriate action their
scholars and you see leads and
many others we didn't just to
focus on the the job thing is.
Trickier for us to get a handle
on that our office doesn't have
that kind of data unfortunately
that's where they go we know
Francis so one of the programs
that I mentioned was that this
you coach which is that tailored
coaching program written by
humans for students --
So we have data from the initial
pilot runs of that.
Intervention in a one of our big
introductory biology courses and
we've seen some very positive
results but that means for
example that we seem changes in
students --
Self their believes in
themselves of students their
study behaviors their study
practices there are grades from
one biology course of the next
biology course but that's but in
the time that we've had that's
those of the metrics we can
collect right now.
So some of the longer term --
Interventions like --
Changes and faculty members
teaching practices most take
longer time to collected on any
other questions.
All right so I think we will
have.
The next.
Said a panelist great thank you.
A good afternoon I'm my name's
Lisa press Cup I served as the
director of admissions.
I've probably worked for the
department of admission since my
graduation in. Nineteen eighty
five thirty three years if
you're doing the math.
I thought it would be best to
start with the mission of the
office of admissions quite
simply were charged with and
rolling the student body that
demonstrates high academic
achievement.
Exceptional personal talent.
And reflects the diversity of
California by providing services
to families and educational
professionals throughout
California.
Our services can be broken down
into the following categories
statewide outreach.
Application services online
services and counselor services.
Statewide outreach includes in
person visits with students from
as far south as San you cedar
high school near the Mexican
border. To the northern most
unity college in California
college of the Siskiyou this
which is fifty miles south of
the Oregon border --
Application services unit
ensures each application is
thoroughly reviewed.
In preparation to submit the
nineteen you see applications
students can view the tutorial
that we've created and posted to
you.
To the tutorial is received
nearly eleven thousand views.
Is commonly used by California
counselors to advise students on
their campuses.
Yes he has been on UCSB is
online tools insure families who
lacked the ability to travel to
campus have access to the
information they need to prepare
for the university.
These tools were created at the
suggestive counselors from low
resource California high schools
who expressed concern that their
families did not have the
resources to visit each UC
campus.
While these tools are available
to anyone with internet access
approximately 85% of the users
are from California.
Lastly our our cancer services
provide tools and resources that
school personnel used to best
serve their students.
The office of admissions is
comprised of fifty dedicated
staff members many of whom are
used.
Graduates all are passionate
about creating educational
access.
Many of our staff myself
included since we understand the
challenges and road blocks.
On the path to attain in a
college degree.
I'd like to highlight some
examples of our successes and
I'll follow that with some
specific services that we
provide.
Families in California.
Fall twenty seventeen marked the
term that you see SB exceeded a
total African American
undergraduate enrollment of one
thousand this was achieved
through long term out reach
program development and a
commitment by the campus
leadership to fund these
initiatives.
Personal attention matters when
it comes to making crucial
enrollment decisions UCSB takes
pride in the personal service.
An example of this would be our
postcard campaign that we
coordinate in the office of
admission.
Last year more than thirteen
thousand underrepresented
students received hand written
postcards from faculty staff
students congratulating them on
their admission to the
university.
Cancer Yang mentioned our
reception since nineteen ninety
four chancer Yang has hosted
eight hundred and twenty eight
receptions throughout California
for top applicants.
In total these programs have
served more than sixty six
thousand students and parents.
Within one hundred UCSB
representatives participating
each program.
Receptions are an example of
campus wide collaboration among
administrators faculty alumni
staff and current students to
bring the best students to UCSB.
Were proud of our reputation for
excellent service counselors
regularly share with us that you
see as be as the office they're
going to call when they have
questions.
The entering class of fall
twenty eighteen reflects the
success of our long standing out
reach programs. 41% of our new
students are first class.
Under represented minority
groups.
There's definitely tons more
work to be done --
All giving announcement samples
of some of our specific
initiatives.
As service California high
schools remain our top priority.
Each fall our outreach team this
is approximately nine hundred
and fifty high schools providing
information about the UC system
and UC Santa Barbara
specifically.
Typically re reach between
ninety thousand and a hundred
thousand students during those
two months of fall out reach.
High school students enrolling
at UCSB for the fall term
eighteen reflect the most
academically talented group of
students in our campus history.
A unique program we coordinate
is our most influential teacher
award each year we ask incoming
freshmen to nominate a teacher
who is impacted their lives.
These teachers receive a
certificate and a thank you
letter and easiest poster to
display in their classrooms.
And a copy of that letter is
also sent to their principal
acknowledging their contribution
to our student success.
Service to California community
colleges is another key priority
UC Santa Barbara is the only
state to visit every California
community college during the
fall application cycle we've
done this for the last three
years.
UCSB maintains a transfer
guarantee programming program
ensuring that students from any
California.
College have access to our
campus we currently have one
admission cam where bass
Sacramento --
This allows us to buy around
services meant to diversity is
reflected in our enrollment
achievements already mentioned
card and pay bed like to share.
Our exit polls.
I have. For you today of our
resource guides --
That address that unique
informational needs of
underserved populations we were
the first you see to create
these guides.
These include informational
guides for American Indian
Chicano Latino African American
Asian American and foster youth
we also produce guides for
veterans.
LGBTQ communities and low income
families with basic needs --
A few of these guys are still at
the printer I put you sample of
just a few of them.
Our LA to SB program provides
low resource Los Angeles schools
with the campus tour experience
that includes bus transportation
from LA to Santa Barbara lunch
in the dining Commons and a
student panel.
Where students can hear from
UCSB students who come from
similar backgrounds?
Through special funding from the
campus we have two full time
professional admission
counselors dedicated to divert
the initiatives one is stationed
in Los Angeles.
There is here on campus together
these it cancers create special
programming serving first
generation students particular
attention is focused on
community based organizations we
have a close relationship with
programs throughout the state
such as the council of African
American parents.
And William Douglas foundation
southern California and the
young scholars program in
Hayward.
UC Santa Barbara is the only you
see to employ an advocacy model
of that reach.
Every American Indian Chicano --
To foster youth applying to UCSB
is assigned an admission
counselor designated as their
advocate.
The advocate make certain that
every applicant has a one stop.
Mayes on so if they had any
questions about any campus
services financial aid housing
whatever the case might be they
have one person that they can
call. To help them navigate the
campus that advocate works with
the student from the point that
they apply until up there
admitted and ultimately enroll
at UCSB to the point they move
into the residence halls.
We maintain close relationships
with UCSB student organizations
who are committed to helping
with the varsity initiatives
when partnership is with the
black student union.
Campus leadership has provided
admissions with permanent
funding to create out reach
programs that focus on African
American high school and
community college students
throughout California.
Our service --
To campus visitors is very
comprehensive the visitor center
serves approximately fifty four
thousand guests annually we
provide a virtual tour of L. one
Spanish Mandarin and Korean. For
families who cannot visit in
person.
Faculty and more than fifty
classes per quarter open their
doors to our campus visitors who
want to have the opportunity to
experience a lecture from
esteemed faculty member.
Finally our online services are
available to those who are not
able to meet with admission
counselors in person.
These services include webinars
virtual transfer advising
appointments online chats
virtual classroom presentations
to Abbott classrooms and online
college fairs.
We also have an expansive array
of videos available to students
on our you tube site with
specific videos produced for
African American Chicano Latino
transfer and foster youth.
Again these online services are
used for students and counselors
for instance 89% of our weapon
our viewers are from California.
We do face some challenges as we
create and implement our
outreach services.
Success can be hampered if our
funding is not consistent across
fiscal years in general most
successful initiatives take two
to three years to fully mature.
And to take root in California
high schools and community
colleges.
What we're tremendously grateful
for any new funding even one
time funding if the funding is
one year only it is more
challenging to realize long term
results?
Comprehensive review of the
application --
Is critical --
We need to fully understand the
talents of a particular student
beyond just GPA and SAT.
Review and a hundred and ten
thousand of those applications
is a massive undertaking --
We use a team of about a hundred
and fifty readers that must
complete this arduous task in
about ten to twelve weeks time.
Applications are far more
complex than when I began in
this profession for example
California community colleges
are offering a very large array
of border called dual enrollment
classes.
Community college courses
offered on the high school
campus.
Many high school students are
completing these courses in
addition they're taking online
courses there attending summer
programs at different colleges
and universities.
So these programs definitely
make it didn't more prepared for
university level work but it
definitely creates a much more
complex application to review.
The mandated two to one ratio of
men to trance moment
[inaudible]
Actually [inaudible]
Camp [inaudible]
Related [inaudible]
See.
There are two community because
Santa Barbara county.
Combined those two community
colleges bring us only 17% 1718%
of our total transfer enrollment.
So that basically means we are
far more reliant than other.
UC's to bring in out of area
students to campus to hit that
two to one mandated ratio.
Average to special populations
such as under represented
minority groups transfer
students veterans and foster
youth require time intensive
services.
Again our geographic location
means that we must travel
throughout communities simply
put the geographic location of
Santa Barbara makes out reach
more expensive.
Demand for stem majors is at all
time high.
This creates tremendous --
Demand for lab space in teaching
assistants which has been
mentioned already today while
the campus is working to address
these issues it mission staff
must work diligently. To help
students discover majors across
all disciplines.
The type of specialty out reach
program requires labor intensive
services.
Finally competition to enroll
our most talented under
represented California students
is fierce.
The biggest concern is financial
aid.
Our low income families are near
panic when they see the total
cost of attendance and middle
income families are deterred by
fear of student loan debt.
It mission cancer spend
significant time addressing
these concerns.
Colleges from outside California
are now placing regional
representatives within
California to recruit our most
promising students away.
These schools offer scholarships
that often cannot be matched by
UC this is starkly black
colleges and universities now
recruit heavily in California.
And host college fairs it at key
California community colleges
the H. B. C. use have also
developed guaranteed admission
programs with the California
community colleges that are
competing with the UC guarantee
programs.
I thank you for your time and
your interest in our out reach
programs I hope this interview.
This overview demonstrates our
passion for service --
And arguments California schools
thank you [inaudible]
The given.
Good afternoon my name is Mike
Miller and I'm the assistant
vice chancellor for enrollment
services.
I'm here to share some of our
innovative work around critical
issues like access affordability
and basic needs.
Thanks to our generous financial
aid awards and several in the
several new programs around
student support UC Santa Barbara
was re recently ranked number
two in a New York times college
access index which ranks
colleges and universities for
their support of low income
students.
While we're proud of a number
two ranking we also we also know
that we have a lot of work to do
and in these areas.
With the rising cost of higher
education and constantly
evolving needs of our students
UC Santa Barbara continues to
look for ways to ensure student
success.
As my colleagues have said
predictable funding models are
vital when trying to plan ahead.
This is something our students
also struggle with traditional
financial aid models determine
eligibility on a year by year
basis.
This means low income first
generation college students
commit to a campus only knowing
how that they'll pay for one
year of their education and are
often left to wonder about years
two three and four four years
ago UC Santa Barbara launch a
pilot program designed to
address this issue.
Call the UCSB promise scholar
program.
The program offers talented hide
high need incoming freshmen a
pretty well for your financial
aid out outlook using existing
financial aid programs.
Transfer students are offered to
years of predictable funding
Kalra and services to ensure
they thrive in the classroom as
well as in the UCSB community.
Here's what we've learned so far
the model a predictable funding
and wrap around services is
working.
We currently have four hundred
fifteen students in the in the
program and of those a hundred
and twenty three year in their
fourth year.
Of the students we welcome the
campus in the first year of the
program all but one remain
enrolled in on track to graduate.
A remarkable 93% are on trial
are on track to graduate in four
years or less.
Into date the overall GPA for
the entire program is a three
point. Three to put this in
perspective the average
household income of our promise
scholars is less than twenty
five thousand dollars a year.
Under normal sort circumstances
we know many of the students
would be at risk of having to
drop out or stop out there in
our academic careers.
Due to financial hardship.
However however under our model
they are thriving graduating and
graduating on time.
Last fall UC Merced launched a
multi your financial aid program
and other UC campuses are
exploring similar similar
efforts.
Another program we recently
implemented that is seeing
positive results is our
financial crisis response team.
National research shows that
when college students drop out
or stop out it is almost always
due to financial obstacles that
tend to be less than five
hundred dollars.
Last fall UCSB launch this this
program which is designed to
catch students before they fall
through the cracks.
A diverse committee meets to
review student you.
Can see five and also connect
with other can to research.
The reason while.
In the committee is currently
[inaudible]
This.
It's who lost homes in both the
will see and campfires.
Last year the undergraduates who
responded reported being food
into care.
With this in mind the global
food initiative and great
efforts like SB eighty five were
launched.
UCSB is taken those resources in
implemented some impactful
programs to ensure our students
have access to help the in the
in nutritious foods.
Our faculty staff and students
are passionate about food
security.
Back in twenty eleven student
leaders launch the campus food
bank.
In its first week of existence
the food banks are five students.
Fast forward to today more than
sixteen hundred students per
week access the campus food bank.
You see SB is also leading the
way in terms of accessing the
cow fresh program.
Nearly three last year nearly
three thousand students took
advantage of the program
resulting in over five million
dollars in purchasing power for
our students.
This year we're on pace or in
role in role six thousand
students in that program far
more than any other UC campus.
UCSB continues to educate
students on things like cooking
healthy meals shopping on a
budget and much more.
The campus also recently broke
ground on a student farm which
will supplier food bank with
fresh produce and service
service a laboratory for our
faculty and students.
Thanks the funding from sources
like SB eighty five you see SB
is quickly and effectively
addressing food and security.
It is important to note the
leadership of assembly member
let alone around it SB eighty
five which is designed to create
hunger free campuses across
California.
This fall we also started a
housing voucher program to help
students were facing short term
housing emergencies.
Through the financial crisis
response team students can apply
for vouchers for up to five
hundred dollars which can be
used for on campus or off campus
housing situations.
These are just a few of the
innovative and intentional
programs you see SB is created
to help students thrive wallop
and those.
Looking ahead many of these
programs have been started using
one time funding funding sources
to ensure these programs remain
in place.
Thank you for your time and your
continued support.
Thank you.
Thank you [inaudible]
Question.
All.
Have if if yeah.
So -- First
of all as the in enrollment has
have a couple questions on that --
Obviously it's a cavity --
UC system and Santa Barbara.
It's just one of you could kind
of paint a picture.
The the odds of getting in.
Now.
Versus like ten years ago right
and then.
You know what's what's the
average.
GPA.
I don't has eighty seven that in
that first third --
Well.
To officially of the dead it is
32% admit rate for UC Santa
Barbara at the freshman level
and 51% for transfer students.
So that means a third of the
students who apply will
ultimately be admitted to Santa
Barbara --
We definitely have become a much
more competitive campus --
I would say from the point we
were not selected but all.
That really has been a hard
thing. For the pulp but just.
We now have --
Winners we are ranked number.
Five Robert or we tried to
explain to students that we
really should not be considered
backup choice campus anymore
that.
Barb is the big leagues.
And determine manned with
[inaudible] Two average SAT is
in the range of thirteen hundred
plus.
And so if if your a at
communicable transfer student
your 50%.
Yeah community college transfer
student the average --
Will we have our guarantee
program.
That -- Says
of student has sixty
transferable units with the
three point two and a few
courses completed specifically
in math and English they're
guaranteed admission to UC Santa
matter what community college
there from no matter what
community colleges so if.
If people come down here and
role at Santa Barbara City
College.
Work we're gonna go visit them
tomorrow yes this do not --
A bit of an that that's out
there that your chances are
better.
I think that the difference
would be cancers at Santa
Barbara City College are very
familiar with the C. S. B. R.
departments and our selection
process.
So students get very good
advising from the cancers at
Santa Barbara City College but a
student at college of the
sequoias has an equal chance.
Under the guarantee --
So the guarantee isn't the to
guarantee that they'll get in to
UCAS speed to guarantee they'll
get into UC campus no it's a
guarantee that they will get
into UC Santa Barbara. Six of
the UC campuses have campus
specific guarantees use you
choose one campus you choose one
tag with.
Solar I'm a student at City
College the Santa Barbara City
College I have it's I have the
the minimum requirements I apply
to UCSB and I'm automatically
accepted.
Or whatever of the six campus.
Actually retailing Davis three
point two in each each kelp each
you see that participated said
there own.
Criteria for their guarantee we
guarantee here's Santa Barbara
Santa read point.
Two so again if you're at Santa
Barbara City College Santa
Monica San Diego three point two
sixty units --
A transferable math to transfer
but to community in Santa
Barbara county only represents
17% of your transworld meant of
your enrollment of our transfer
enrollment each year show how
many students actually apply
from city college --
From from Santa Barbara city
it's a ballot between nine
hundred and a thousand I'd have
to pull the data from the most
recent years but it's it's
actually been declining because
Santa Barbara City College is a
moment has been declining.
Yeah hi on the agenda it says
that -- The
its it that increased by 30%.
Community college transfers but
Pressman has gone down right
transfer that's one thing too if
you look you know.
It's all great but for the
California's family that we're
talking about may times the
freshman it's that I Anderson
can of coke.
And that's that in nineteen two
thousand nine there is nineteen
thousand fifteen freshman and
this year. Nineteen three forty
so.
Comfortable over three hundred
more freshmen and non resident
increased. Seven thirty I rob.
To that.
We get that question quite
frequently like like I tried to
say our priority is still
California 86% of our outreach.
That we conduct in the office is
California --
There is something called
compare favorably that our
faculty hold.
All the campus is to and that is
all students must meet the same
academic standards so with the
number of applications we have
again trying to grow the campus
academic profile student is in
the application pool.
Were evaluating all aspects of
their application we do want
diversity whether it be
geographical with in California
whether it be ethnic whether it
be national and global we do.
Maintain a clear understanding
and belief in the region cap of
18% the campus at Santa Barbara
is at 16% we feel like that
gives our students --
Great global exposure --
The same time we're also
promoting our students to study
abroad and bring back that
knowledge from their study
abroad program so we think
predict balance right now
favorably we tighten up the law.
Last year's and now.
Yes specifically it can't be
does he have to equal to or
better than the California
student for them we give me.
Thirds yeah.
I wanted to ask about the
outreach programs are.
Big supporter them and again I
guess are not called out
reaching more in state pap.
Like that I'm there are some
programs that receive special
being called saved up action --
Are to some of our transfer out
reach program so that they had a
big.
Question is that. Twenty years
ago student centered ones are
like that nay step.
Your P. there than very very
well there's the school centered
once and rats reforming.
The schools and Santa three are
in a press.
Whatever they interpreted the
pipeline.
That's a lot of work and a lot
of money in the students are
ones is.
A five students who are on the
bubble.
Any get them closer so you get
this is transform. Thousand
students but you could maybe
hand pick itself.
Someone say that's kind of
creaming because you're just
getting sick people who are just
about their what do you.
What do you think the worthiness
of of those and and what could
we do tend? To have especially
want.
To focused on you know.
Diverse city of our of our of
our UC system in right and wrong
more African American and Latino
students right.
I think it's a combination of
both you know you need a
combination of both we were
frequently in our out reach
encountering phenomenal students
with phenomenal GPAs.
Of from we a first generation
families I had no idea that they
would even be competitive they
you know you talk to them it's
like well I think I'll probably
just go to my local community
college.
Which is not a bad option it's
an option I took as a first
generation student.
But without fully realizing the
financial aid that was available
to me so the admissions office.
Meet thousands of those kinds of
stew about great has community
college is an option but let's
get your application into you
see as well and and let's see if
we can make that work for you at
the same time I think our early
out reach programs that are
funded.
Through the say pet funds --
Are essential to creating that
pipeline for the families that
just really have no background
knowledge of higher education a
missile amount and I go way back
working with the local program
in Santa Barbara called cal soap.
And you know cal soap is a
program that works with first
generation families this state
funded.
And the immediate out reach
offices like mind in close
conjunction with those programs
so at the same time that we're
doing Sir the large scale
blanket covering of the state of
California we also work very
closely with those say pet
programs.
I think you need both yeah.
Okay [inaudible]
Thank you.
I am curious --
About the call a community
college promise program an
impact it's had on admissions or
maybe it hasn't had an impact --
On the community college side we
have seen an and unbelievable
statewide enthusiasm for these
promise programs a grain unity
college --
And we're just trying to
identify is some of the
anecdotal information that we
received it equivalent to what
you're all starting to see or is
it too early to tell --
Because it hasn't really been
adopted --
You know I'm.
In a kind of a stronger way at
the statewide level starting
certainly our community college
adversity college has adopted I
just wonder if you can speak to
that.
Yeah I'm definitely starting to
see some of the results of that --
I think there are great options
for students I am starting to
see more still the first choice
option as a result of those
problems programs.
I think that especially.
Yeah hi performing community
colleges like Santa Barbara City
College that also offers honors
programs.
In conjunction with their
promise programs are very
enticing families.
I can I ask you a question about
that comment.
From your perspective is it
enticing tell all families or a
are they are the combination of
promise and honors enticing to
families that --
Or students that come from
families who are not first
generation horn right I mean.
Right I think as the as you've
mentioned --
This demand for you see there's
a prestige that goes with you
see and families want that
prestige and there is a certain
set of families.
Usually the non of first
generation those with college
experience and their families
that.
Typically we're not considering
the community colleges before --
And wood.
In our outreach efforts
sometimes even be a bit offended
if we brought up a transfer
option and I am now seeing.
Those families locally looking
at last of the again I also see
that first generation family who
often things that's their only
option and again it's a great
option if they've done all the
research and determine that's
the best that school for them.
I just too often see students
assume that the four year
universities are not an option
and I I like to know courage
students to explore at all.
Thank you does that answer your
question it does yeah.
And and all for a view spoke at
the end.
Of the and consistent funded and
I higher at ninety eight the
community colleges benefit to
some extent of from prop ninety
eight but certainly not. For
your schools so while we are
interested and I think recession
through.
To the start of a real
[inaudible]
That's right.
I'm for higher and what is that
look like is in no viable is it
not.
What other elements it?
Would you have us think about
that's not funding related in
terms of the legislature and
direction to support the student
from out reach to admissions to
enrollment to graduation.
And beyond.
Besides funding [inaudible]
Thanks Hyundai [inaudible]
It.
And it's one we grab.
Well I would I would say yeah
just.
More conversations like this I
think are incredibly valuable
for instance the two to one
ratio I completely understand
that I'm a product like I said
of the community college and it
was a good start for me --
But it also when were trying to
get very creative with our
outreach efforts and we're
trying to reach as many students
as possible.
Sometimes being bound to such a
restrictive policy with zero
wiggle room for instance that
two to one is is is an exact
count.
Of the ratio we must maintain.
And so sometimes like we were
all and so we are.
Doing all these special efforts
just to make sure we get those
last ten students enrolled.
That's taking up an enormous
amount of time and resources so
I would also say sometimes a
little bit more flexibility in
understanding the challenges of
the work that we're doing --
Would go a long way in allowing
us to do really what we think is
best for the students.
I think one thing that I would
add is is just taking advantage
of the programs that currently
exists so right now the
California student aid
commission will reach out.
To cal grant recipients letting
them know that they qualify for
the conference program.
Couldn't we somehow have those
instead of having students have
to to apply for the conference
program just create a pipeline
and automatically connect them
with the resources on my bill
idea this between eighteen are.
Worth thinking about.
Yeah.
And I would can I just add one
thing and at the goes back to
senator Jackson's question.
I'm about how we measure things.
On the kinds of metrics that you
all look for and think about
when we indicate what success
looks like I think building on
leases response having
conversations about what success
looks like some what those
metrics look like together.
Can really help us all
understand each other.
And bill programs that are more
sustainable as well.
You know one of the things that
I think has been sort of
governor of brown's whole
approaches graduation --
You once graduation numbers
doesn't necessarily demonstrate
that someone actually has gotten
a quality education.
The graduated --
There's got to be a happy medium
somewhere in between where we
can judge the quality of that
education as well as their
graduation.
And maybe that's because here
with you --
Because I still believe that the
goal of education is to teach
people how to think critically.
Not necessarily just to get a
job -- It
and perhaps the answers again
somewhere in the middle there --
The notion you have to scramble
to meet your two to one ratio of
courses frustrating --
On the other hand what we see is
a legislature is sometimes
people really start fudging the
numbers and taking advantage of
some of that flexibility so.
Maybe that somewhere to where we
could find that happy medium.
As far as the graduation I don't
want to diminish.
What you said?
But in not much at that so much
at the UC but say really that's
a CSU issue but still the UC if.
The more students who graduated
at and I wanna go over this
three point nine years. For your
freshman and are. Nine three
nine four replace all that still
that's pretty remarkable and I
think it's lower than --
C. S. look most UC's and you
know now we have.
Students who get the Pell grant
in the summer is.
That that's just.
The graduate is for a pair of
time.
It's more access for other
students treat try to get in so --
One thing that's kind of been
frustrating.
For many years this.
Is like someone saying earlier
that here in the summer.
Mister Haynes was saying that is
to say did campus and in the
have the buildings and it's
everything's here so.
How do we better utilize --
The facilities year round.
That's been that's been a topic
that's been going on for decades
yeah.
Well.
I think it's changes it's
changing and we actually have a
number of very innovative summer
programs about that how are
getting more students well our
office of our office of summer
sessions and is very
entrepreneurial actually has
worked in collaboration with
many of our other offices.
Whatever continuing education is
now called which I forgotten --
They just change the name but
they've got a number of really
really innovative programs that
are joint programs --
In sort of academic slash
professional programs --
Journalism a public advocacy is
one programs like that that are
going on in the summer we also
have a number very innovative --
Bridge programs for students so
we have a freshman summer star
program that runs in our seconds.
Second major summer sessions
about six weeks before the fall
quarter starts.
That's really really booming and
it's an excellent transition
programs the data show that
students who start in that
program especially under
represented students.
Really do remarkably well I'm
coming in the fall quarter I
mean all of our students where
the American please I know that.
Housing that a crunch and
housing is empty housing is the
biggest for free right there
your I'm camps are doing stuff
like that in --
My soft ASEAN is also doing a
lot with online courses for
students who can't afford to
stay in the summer you go home
and work or family connections
so that our summers actually
doing a lot of online yeah.
And Mike's office as a new
program to fought a support
students who to staying cam
thousand during the summer right
we we've been trying to expand --
Funding options for students to
be able to it the young not only
attend so if they attend full
time and they're they're taking
at least twelve units will pay
450% of their housing on campus.
So is that is that three point
nine four because the students.
Start as a freshman taken a much
of course isn't that they
already have a semester done or
is it because they're taking
more than fifteen person master.
Yes summer summer yes a
combination.
Of yeah.
A lot of the APA college level
courses summer courses the
freshmen summer start it's a
very very common now to see a
student who.
Enters as a freshman.
Actually have enough units to be
sophomores and even juniors were
seen an increase in the number
of high school students have
already completed their general
education course. For students
are looking for ways to shave
off costs graduating early is
one yeah definitely.
Well I was thinking you know of
the to get that final credit
taking underwater basket weaving
I mean that's yeah.
That's not quite what we're
trying to accomplish but no and
actually I don't think that's
what.
They're doing so much my date
maybe so but no we're seen
students think very
strategically students are very
outcome focus so regardless of
their major. For instance they
might be --
A science student who wants to
add a minor in professional
writing because they you know
think we'll and then and you
know how to write grant so I'm
going to add the minor in
professional rite aid --
So students [inaudible]
Well [inaudible]
State.
You could say a fifty year
because fees were affordable now
students are looking for ways.
To graduate early or if they're
going to stay the four full
years and maybe a quarter more.
It needs to be because they're
supplementing their resume with --
A study abroad with a and
experience will program that is
going to make them more
marketable and increasingly were
creating programs that build in
that kind of experience for
students even in that sort of
more traditional quote unquote
liberal arts education.
In my day students tried to stay
in school for five years to
avoid the draft.
I don't know if anybody
remembers anyone here was of
that era but now students to
trying to graduate early moment
their their viability in the
workforce.
Strategic via an on that topic I
actually want to follow up at
the center and I just came from
a hearing related to natural
disaster response.
And it's certainly --
Very important issue --
At the state level and one of
the things that has come up has
been.
What's the role of our research
institutions --
In helping us address I mean.
Something that's so big that all
the experts are.
Still struggling to figure out
what we do about the wild fires
and as I hear these
conversations about --
Students --
Bean outcome driven I mean
certainly I worked here in the
term time to degree matter to
last.
I think about the senator's
comment related to we also want
them to be critical thinkers --
In in my case at I I have a
special place for undergraduate
research on and research
altogether and wanting students
to yes get these degrees and get
very practical --
Skills that will help them
certainly as we tackle monster
issues we need the critical
thinkers we need the researchers
to help us tackle problems that
are.
Bigger than us right now --
Can you speak to some trends
that you're seen around --
Students I mean are they still
getting these experiences is
that an area where we are doing
a good job of investing maybe
not doing as great of a job
investing because that is so key
to the state of California.
Effect yes so we just are in the
process of reviewing
undergraduate research and
creative activities grant so
that's one of the major
undergraduate research programs
in the college of letters and
science on our application
numbers or up hugely this year
like by. Twenty or 30% --
And so that's are at the program
where students conduct
independent research we also
have a program a sort of gateway
programmer students work with
faculty.
List research in a directory
also up twenty or 30% so we know
that undergraduates are keenly
interested in that research
experience and we know how
important that research
experience is as you.
I'm for real.
Helping students to not just.
Around important issues.
Yet undergraduate research has
always been a key feature of the
UCSB education --
My role as associate vice
chancellor Frederick education
is sort of a new role in
creating this office of
undergraduate education but I
the the to sort of keep things
that we're creating as capstone
for students with undergraduate
research is an on campus
experience and then.
Study abroad is you know you see
SB use education abroad as
always but I also queued spirit
here.
But we're making maybe keep
capstone experiences for
students
video if you look at
brochures you see edges in read.
Which is heavily.
Mode probably the most request.
And at those reached.
But the chancellor has let all
these years is what is it the
opportunities to get involved in
research we are seeing a lot
more students coming to the
university from.
International Baccalaureate
programs I'd be programs where
critical thinking.
Is pushed dramatically in
students start getting research
experience in high school and
they're looking for that
experience when they get to the
university one of the things we
talk to students who have a lot
of those Advanced Placement
units and I'd be on at some.
College credits before they come
is what that's going to allow
you to do is get involved in out
reach lighten your schedule a
little bit to allow more time.
For those experience of programs
for outreach so our skis me for
research so.
We start talking about research
the point that we are recruiting
this student you'll see
information about the McNair
scholars programs in our email
campaigns that we sent to
students.
We try to use McNair scholars
for instance --
In our student profiles of
success --
That we highlight and all of our
informational brochures we also
I just will add to have programs
that help students develop to
become undergraduate researchers
McNair is a kind of capstone
experience but those early
gateway programs are so
important.
Because they help students learn
to do that and faculty are very
very invest in those programs as
well.
Thank you 5% 55% yes yes 55% of
undergrad actually.
56% of undergraduates.
You.
Thank you so much will now
proceed with our our final panel.
Last but not least of course is
our faculty and students.
Perspective. Seven other
students go first [inaudible]
Okay -- Hi
there my name's modeling laden
occurs on a thank you --
For coming here to the campus
it's a lot easier that you're
here rather than us tracking you
down.
Yes but I am a thirty year
history of public policy major
at UCSB --
And I've had the opportunity to
where thirty year and work where
you work and I came here --
Nobody had a conversation with
me about what the UC's are
actually like and so when I came
here the reality was very
different from what I was told
about with you see could offer
me -- I
found myself organizing for for
students that don't have housing
they don't have food I'm trying
to fight for it some funding for
sexual assault resources on our
campus --
Issues that I didn't think we're
going to be this prevalent in US
state funded institution that I
grew up hearing that --
Was one of the best in the world.
And so that was first very
startling for me and then the
long that I went into it another
interesting thing that I learned
was disparities between the UC
campuses --
That was a concept that never
had occurred to me before that
there could be a campus like you
see more sad --
Not like so many basic resources --
Compared so UC Berkeley that has
been here for a long time but
the students both.
Of you know.
This is of our kids a six
infinitely plate.
So that was really --
Israel.
All the students protesting at
Berkeley and on our campuses
were actually trying to yell
really loudly because people
work during that --
And that they've been in the
situation for a long time and
that we've had a breaking point
where -- You
see students and and it's
something that I'm really
passionate about.
So something that I find you
need about the nineteen sixty
California hired master plan
beyond --
The creation of a really unique
higher public education system
is that how the authors and
legislators and higher education
leaders --
And it.
Of a lot of pressure due to a
president population growth
still maintain the idea that
higher education needs to be
affordable --
And so I think that was a really
unique idea for the time and I
think that there's a lot of
parallels but we're experiencing
now.
And I understand that we have a
huge population pressure on a
sound number in very different
circumstances.
But I also understand that the
situation where an especially
with increased funding in our
state is a policy choice --
And it's a policy choice that
students aren't really going to
put up with anymore and I think
that's been very evident over
the past couple of years --
And beyond that to the the
nineteen sixty eight I
California of higher education
plan.
Really only pave the way for a
type of education Ford students
that our state actually saw
getting higher education at the
time.
That means we're still relying
on a system that over
prioritizes white students can
be schools --
A system that was heralded for
it's time and still today for
the opportunities that it
created but Dodd.
Disproportionately created on
for five very small portion of
our state --
And it's still being represented
on every single one of our
campuses.
So -- These
even very interesting cation
works not just at the UC's but
in California.
In general --
And seeing as this conversation
is more focus on you see SB
there are some issues that I
want to point out that idea and
I have experienced every time
here that I work with a lot of
students about --
One of the issues that we have
been made of aware of this year
is a lack of funding for
undocumented student resources
on a campus.
So as I'm sure you're aware the
C. office of the president --
Is not going to renew the
funding sources that they're
getting.
And study there having that job
done the chances to fundraise
UCSB receives the least amount
of money for are undocumented
Ste bursting services and we
also have the lowest amount.
And as I'm sure that's
proportional --
As I'm sure that's proportional
that's still not adequate we
should be and rolling a lot of
undocumented students we should
be making sure that the students.
Are not going to have to fight
for resources from their chance
are for funding but they should
be like actually being taken
care by the state the state
needs to fight for all the
students that our public system.
Thankless undocumented students
that also includes non resident
students --
As I read in this.
In this agenda back up 16% --
Of UCSB is population that's a
huge portion and the students
are carrying a huge load --
On their shoulders to pay for
this institution that we
shouldn't necessarily have to
pay for it.
And I tuition is making up such
a large portion.
Of of the California --
Of the funding and a huge
percentage that is coming from
non resident students were being
punished solely because they're
from a different state but
really really respect
institution that they're going.
To and that.
As I know personally from a lot
of my out of state students are
really dedicated to staying in
California and getting a job
here -- And
working in these can be is that
we've all learned to love.
So beyond that there's issues
such as mental health services
are caps here only has five
concerts for sexual assault --
Survive use we also they as I
recently got information from
that only plan to see if forty
people per day there now
currently sing seventy people
per day --
There are a lot of instances in
the UC's when people have spoken
to the concert and said this is
a dire emergency and they have
been told to wait two weeks.
I'm not to help dire emergency
is what it is that is an
emergency --
And we are at this institution
and the situations that were in
because of a lack of funding are
contributing to increasing
mental health issues.
And that's a true that just
needs to be spoken on it needs
to be addressed and a lot of
students I mean I mean I come in
incline [inaudible]
Missing -- I
think it's hard as a student
[inaudible]
Just.
And is not a true that were told
me calm and a lot of kids come
here and they face really severe
basic needs issues as well --
In this reality and and it's
interesting having these
conversations about how best to
remediate the situation that
were put in --
With people that have the
ability to change it so --
I would just like to remind you
all that again this is a policy
choice I understand there are a
lot of different factors playing
into it and is a unique
relationship between the UC and
the state --
But as we saw last year through
a lot of our students lobbying
efforts and in the funding that
we got from the state --
There's really who really an
important need to look past that
and address the real issue --
And really look at the students
and like how we can benefit the
state.
And also in a very humane level
think about the situation that
they're trying to live through
just to receive an education.
Thank you thank you.
K. -- Good
afternoon Assemblymembers thank
you for having me here.
My name is combine our state
which a cook when I'm of what
their politicized major diverse
a cop points out Barbara.
I'm also the vibration where you
from it unless riverside versus
seven thousand is a kind of
moved around a lot.
It's almost the bottom tropical
is for Betty C. which is to run
activists group here at base and
hours campus.
Now less of the goals for but
you see actually push for a bill
to extend the coverage summer
maybe there are.
Fifty three now fortunately all
bill failed.
But in the process after
consulting là about to look at
some of the people involved in
decided to bring it back.
And so we reached out to use as
a it was a California
association would need a
partnership with them.
And of also reached out to the
constitution association percent
212%.
What that means is that per UC's
to that's a fifty thousand
dollar drop in thirty years?
See you do that's eleven
thousand dollar drop.
What hasn't up in the process is
the need for college graduates?
And or the same public policy is
to California would have a
college graduate of sort of one
point one billion but you're
twenty third.
And that's all the more
conservative estimates I believe
this difficult to access has the
number on two million.
Not in spite of this
California's I'd give systems
are still not graduating enough
to is on time.
So now in this process also door
trivialize what the she's been
because we are very much aware
that the UC is leading a lot of
situations in graduate instance
of color.
And they should be commended
applauded for that.
But even here at the you see if
we compare pocket recipients to
non public recipients and use
improper as a indication of
income status we know they're
not progress if it's a graduated
rate of 7% of for years.
Whereas question Reyes and black
and brown powder recipients are
graduating rates below 50% of
the accidents about 40% for
browsers around 46%.
And the reason I bring up these
where graduation rate is because
these institutions are market to
us as for institutions so we're
not to look at the six a
graduation rates were injured in
the for you because that's how
it was sold to us will be
applied.
Now this is the system we know
that the numbers even what does
Wall.
Whether the entices you that
also universes of operation
there for you graduation rates
aren't around 25%.
Which is pretty sad.
We will push for expanding
access to financial aid because
when a send up the a currently
people low income students we
still don't have access based on
how the was the set up of
financial aid in California.
Will also push for legislation
that understands that it's not
enough just look at tuition fees
which need to look at the entire
total cost of attendance.
Because they've been such as
housing and text books that are
making higher education a
barmaid good based on income.
Now do you governor legislator
what we're hoping is that.
He always damp us. For the sole
reason that we are definitely
going to come back with
everything to bring these issues
up or pay to fight up until a
couple legislator.
Remembers that when you invest
in students invest in the future
California politically and
economically.
Well the question to you all as
we all sat with us I hope you
have that is yes and I like to
thank you for having
[inaudible]
Thank you --
Good afternoon that term McCarty
and assemblymember the moment
senator Jackson's --
My name in shining bone I'm
professor of economics and chair
of the UC Santa Barbara economic
sent.
A check to the first four time
coming to send a private.
Here right here.
Yup.
Speak on the fact.
The of my colleagues --
Made a long term commitment to
the campus the university and
and the state of California. To
start that pitted chime in with
the students and and and we're
proud to be probably the best
public university system in in
the world based on the you know
master plan and and the the
build up of the and the system.
We have high standards on what
we think what it takes to give
students a first rate education
and we want to give students a
first rate education.
In.
Given that we're were greatly
disappointed by that the
downward trend in state funding --
You know when app in enough
relative and per capita relative
to the state budget and whatever
and measure you want to take.
You know looking back over the
twenty five years that I've been
here that we've gotten whacked --
In every recession should be
here gotten severe budget cuts
and in every downturn we have
failed to get comparable budget
Gaines to reinstate the cuts
that were there for me before.
And frankly I am a little bit
afraid that we are keeping up
with the trend as you expressed
concerns about a possible
recession come forward.
We still have not recovered from
the two thousand eight cuts
despite couple years of you know
moderate --
Funding increases but let me
focus on Santa Barbara and see
few things about our campus --
Comment on that the
presentations made or Brough
lords campus and in proud of it --
We're focused on giving students
a top quality education and and
a broad range of disciplines in
the humanities and the sciences
and engineering.
And we don't really have a lot
of professional schools the only
one we have is focused on the
environment and that's I think
very telling it's it's a focus.
Of research across a lot of the
disciplines but that makes us
more dependent on state support
than many other campuses and so
we're always hoping that our
efforts are appreciated and in
Sacramento and we're hoping for
your support there.
And we also feel like we're
willing to the new campus and
we're growing we're getting
better so despite.
You know all the obstacles at
our trajectory as is up and
we're basically optimistic about
our capabilities --
If we get the at least decent
funding on the research side --
Reputation is planning a
licensing the chancellor
explained at some of that.
Our research funding is now
almost equal to our entire state
funding and that's that's at the
British significant.
On the teaching side we're
becoming both more diverse and
more selective.
I mean diversity and inclusion
are are obviously core values.
There's student email.
We're also doing own fundraiser
in in the quarter areas of you
know funding for classrooms
teaching labs --
Maintenance other core support
that's that's a challenge for
which we need --
Some support.
Now that turned perhaps most
important the purpose of this --
Hearing.
We have pretty good relations
between the faculty and the
university administration and
you see in in general.
Is known for the principle of
shared gov and switch allows
faculty to work through the
academic Senate to participate
in --
Universal decision making and
I'm pleased to see that you're
UC Santa Barbara shared
governance is is working really
well and I'm.
Credit our chancellor for making
a point of consulting faculty
and other campus groups.
On on important issues and
setting the right tone and as
you know the chancellor has made
a long term commitment like many
of the faculty to this.
Campus which is confidence
inspiring in the shared
governance it to some of the
needs me on to to comment on the
presentations by the by the
chancellor's.
And nine others.
Most of what they said is really
not news to read --
Pretty broadly with that and I'd
like to make that and be that
understood as a as a you know
endorsement off the the issues
we've heard.
The you know struggling with the
rise and often a problem and
what --
Enormous.
Certainly strongly supportive
off and capital projects and I I
was delighted by your comments --
Term McCarthy about a potential
on the ship that would help us
greatly that came to friction
[inaudible]
For then at if you.
Faculty concern as granted
students faculty renewal and and
and quality control.
Granted students specially PhD
students are really central to
research university.
And we're really troubled by the
slipping sheer graduate students
at UC Santa Barbara when we
formulated a long range academic
plan about fifteen years ago the
act graduate student share was
13% and the centerpiece of that
plan was to raise that share
270% to to a better job --
In in that area instant the
shares declined 211% and and
that's really disturbing.
It hurts so ability to teach
undergraduates because the PhD
student service key ace.
In hurt so intelligent to
previous research because to PhD
students are also that research
is as it.
Should be --
Because teaching advanced topics
are simply impossible blessed
instructors on the edge of
research in their respective
fields and the PhD students are
really at the center of that.
Second one of my medicine on
faculty renewal.
Many of our faculty here and
there in in their fifties and
sixties and many of us love our
job so much at least --
Stay way longer than its
financially attractive but
eventually people retire.
And at that's a problem because
the university has really taken
a systematic advantage off --
Faculty members loyalty it's
well known that long serving
faculty --
Often except below market
salaries without immediately
threatening to move.
And think it's we sort of get
used to buildings falling to
disappear com on this we pay in
equities credit [inaudible]
And the space for them to come
and feel comfortable in into
space.
So -- Units
because economist paying below
market salaries in deferring
maintenance is a great short
term strategy for for saving
money.
But it's really not a
sustainable solution and we're
concerned about faculty renewal
and needing more attention.
Going forward most one is better
quality control and and
specifically that the principle
of of peer review.
At this is worth emphasizing
giving this you know growth and
reporting requirements fed beef
experience over many years and I
would have to say I have no
problem with and accountability
provided those to ask us for
data also.
You know pay for the staff to
provide all those data which is
a source of growth and in in
staffing.
But the point one make is that
as far as I can tell the
quantitative matrix really don't
to the heart of how the
university works. To keep
principle years peer review when
we produce research.
Is not recognized until
validated by independent reviews
and we apply the same principle
to teaching it to the
organization of the universities
for shared governance.
In every course has course
evaluation each faculty member
is revealed every at least every
five years typically. Two and a
two or three every department is
regularly reviewed by outside
experts that examine the quality
instruction quality of research
quality of the curriculum.
And those reviews look at
metrics non commercial aspects
of quality and so the the great
strength of peer review.
Is that combines measurement but
good judgment and the message
that I'm trying.
To say is that I messed. For
called guy.
Benchmarks Richard roles like
the two to one ratio for
freshman transfers that burger
ever mentioned.
And we believe we believe for a
truck that we need sort of
deserve some trust because we
have a fairly deeply.
Ingrained culture of peer review
and shared governance.
And that provides a much more
rigorous quality control that
anybody could and maple is found
that from challenges and and ask
for your support.
All we really need is stable and
reasonable funding level in a
measure of trust that lived
through such funding
appropriately.
And we will.
Thank you enough.
Printer answer questions.
Thank you I have a few questions
and comments --
Back -- In
the day is the state of
California I think put in fifty
eight cents.
Of every dollar the university
spent we're now down who is it
seventeen or eighteen sense.
So we really have lost that
commitment the university
California used to be free --
That was the commitment that
anyone who could.
Qualify I would get a free
education because they do bring.
Your comments absolutely
accurate.
Most of the students who go to
university California want to
stay here in California and most
of are you see SB grads want to
stay here I mean they're smart.
Who I just came from Chicago in
a snowstorm who once lived
through their life's too short?
So -- Part
of it is that we've lost sense.
But that being said.
We are trying to identify our
our neediest students and
provide as much funding as
possible and I do know I don't
know the exact numbers here you
UCSB.
The number of students who get
Pell grants and cal grant St god
only knows what all there is but
when you work with students and
and help them.
Most most of the students who
needed don't pay tuition.
But they do have to pay for
living expenses so.
I'm not sure why where the
university can come in and and
I'm.
I'm trying to respond to your I
think very eloquent and and
accurate concerns about.
It getting education here how
how do we how do we do that on
eighteen cents to the dollar --
Versus fifty eight cents to the
dollar which we used to do I
think it was back in the sixties --
So.
The the you know funding I mean
there's a movement right now
frankly that I disapprove.
A intensely in privatizing all
of education.
We're saying that University
Michigan comes to mind I think
that schools basically been
privatized --
I think it's a foolhardy effort
and a bad.
One but we've done a little bit
of that here in.
In California so.
I I think one of the questions
that I had --
In this whole discussion and by
the way I do want to agree with
you mental health services are
completely inadequate I put
money in our budget.
As a member that the sub
committee I think was a a twenty
five million dollars which would
put money in for each of the
UC's to start dealing with some
of the mental health issues were
saying.
With our students in the
governor took it out we have new
governor coming in he said
higher education is a priority
of his and I'm hoping.
This will be one of those --
Priorities --
I do agree if we gray in the
summer that was one of the
things I was told there the cost
of a of a unit is higher in the
summer.
No funding available who the
heck's going to take advantage
of but the that you made a
statement that were over
prioritizing white students.
So I'd like you to clarify that
a little bit for me particularly
in light of the statements that
we heard here how we're doing
out reach out we're getting a a
pretty significant number of
underserved.
Students 40% or the first my
family to graduate nor making
efforts but could you explain to
me what you.
What you mean by over
prioritizing white students
[inaudible]
Yeah. To say is.
I'm thirty and I think it's
white --
Other.
But representative of what
California is --
And I think it's a simple as
that [inaudible]
Well.
Okay what percentage of
California it is white.
I have no idea I'm.
Well the reason I ask is that I
think we are we are certainly a
minority majority stake minority
up within quotes.
So that the state is comprised
more of a communities of color
but I'm I'm.
I'm not sure the 31% isn't over --
Reflection of the white
population which is why I assets
under -- I
would think is we can talk about
when we talk about hard has and
let's look at Lassen
specifically because eyes to all
the service president PS you
pleasure.
And all these which we saw as
for the longest time our
statistics were blaster
publishers around what would
hover between 2% 3% even though
we know that and then the
technician whiner là yeah 30%
by being up with there.
And so we knew that --
Pretty much and therefore in the
state of California it's aye
these are five selections but
even with the blasters who work
here.
There was a person of us was
there so I think the has been
somewhat of a push to create
more programs to incorporate
lessons but it will look at the
service of what actual license
were saying here.
Some of those things are very
does with the like I don't like
up in my county some things that
happen on my campus does.
It make you feel like an
outsider there's a lot of
stories about that and so is
efforts to like try and put --
I noticed it was a trying to
Lassen on missions right now
what would be issue too great a
mentorship program.
Which takes students were
license here won't be here for
awhile and mentor them.
And because part of the reason
is that's when that program was
created by blacks was actually
because we saw that allows it to
become if they don't have that
connects to a community.
And so this is.
It is a bit of a problem it is
actually quite a major problem
because this is a bet on one
situation where somebody said
it's like their first I'm just
being from here.
And so having no sense of
community having those it's a
connection to people look like
you.
That becomes an entire problem
and if your first and Reyes and
you haven't been access these
resources I give a talk at the
Mike action is the promise of
our program.
Bombs go program actually put a
lot of black students two years
ago -- The
procession work with them over
summer.
And what it is which we noticed
about the promise of our program
is that the reason why the big
you for a long time there was a
blind spot in universities ought
not realizing that.
These dessert institutional
knowledge that by not being from
that family which has led to
some go to college actually
lackey.
At and I don't disagree with you
I in fact I think you're
absolutely correct and that's
been my understanding --
Particularly with African
American students on campus.
The statement.
Our ties.
Students I'd like some.
What that means?
I'm not getting.
The concept is cut and I agree
that we have not been and one of
things we try to do is wrap
around services for first
generation students --
You know whose families don't
have a history that they're not
able to land the kind of support
that's necessary I get that but
how are we over prioritizing
white students.
So in saying that it's not
necessarily something that so
over it --
As I think it used to be and
higher education systems whether
it's through admissions up and
it's been a lot of efforts to
remediate it but it's it's
evident through --
A lack of funding for even on to
resources --
For things that a lot of
students from white families are
like what stands --
Hive economically like.
Better situations instance of
color on a campus and the state
and the universities and ability
to acknowledge how that has a
significant impact on their
ability to succeed here --
I think.
Is we are trying to create
opportunities for them to come.
And so there are efforts --
To encourage look that --
Motions of color comes our
campus and that they state their
graduation --
I do think that it is a
disservice to students of color
that were not acting as fast as
we should on that we're not
debate reading enough resources
to these programs --
And it's beyond recruitment and
retention it's down to basic
needs programs it's down to the
mental health programs it's down --
To recruiting motions of color
for our graduate school --
Stuff like that so while it's
not and maybe that covered that
state and I said can to receive
be perceived as a little.
Boy and I I do think that it is
a situation that is that dire
our public higher education
system should be a system in
which we can help alleviate the
disparities between people of
color and white people in the
state of California --
And I just think that it can do
better and I wanted to do better.
Than it already is and I think
part of it starts before college
coming Ted definitely so.
So I appreciate that because
yeah.
I I hear what you're saying I'm
not not taking to consider what
the injures in the new and who
are first generation color who
haven't the same opportunities --
Because of family.
Comes sizzle.
The general fund is associated.
Education we don't need as much
okay.
As we do perhaps in some of our
from middle class white
community site I get that I
agree with that.
It's it justice to say were over
prioritizing white students I
think is.
It moves me sort of in a focus
and I'm not sure I understand.
Thank you and I think it's
important to let me --
Interjected appreciate back in
the back and forth is if you
look at higher and in general --
Which but your point earlier
center Jackson's rise how much
California used to invest in
higher ed.
That's when they California
educate hired system UC and CSU.
Was very very Caucasian and now
an era I think this the FAA from
the CSU system prospecting last
year talk.
The overall deal as the as the
university system is getting
more brown the state commitment
to higher ed is going down.
Trying to make a rhyme there but
that that I think that is the is
the picture that that we have to
always realize is that in
California at higher education
funding --
That's it that's reality but but
back -- To I
appreciate you letting that the
student perspective.
And I I do think it is important
some of things that we're
grappling with.
Is is -- If
we had to sit cases here of
let's say a billion dollars.
Right.
So for UC and CSU you could take
that improperly fund.
And I know UC's use you're
asking for five hundred million
of pieces for their budget and
that's we should ask because we
need.
But you can you can --
Stop the UC system pay for
compensation pay for deferred
maintenance the basic.
Needs -- Do
debt load housing hunger.
Food security the whole works
and so you could have the other
suit billion dollar suitcase.
And it reactive reinvested in
financial late which is what.
We've been trying to the
assembly last couple years
basically --
Expand the cal grant give you an
add on cal grant to not just you
tuition but help pay for your
cost of living your Bucks
transportation housing and so
forth and you know that's that's
our job that's what the budget
subcommittee do is.
Grapple with these scarce
resources that compete with
health care and early education
and child care and pre school
and after school programs in the
works and and you know that's
our problem but you your job is
to we 100% understand that and I
appreciate you.
Letting that perspective and you
know we're gonna get back out of
twenty nineteen and I think
there is.
There's an opportunity we have
that at the new governor as as
was mentioned to campaign
heavily on higher education --
We have a little bit of new --
Increase revenue and in the
twenty eighteen twenty nineteen
budgets [inaudible]
There is [inaudible]
Find.
From you know early cation
through K. twelve th hired
because we're not you know.
Funding what we need as far as
the outcome you know.
You'd be here --
You know what word just --
Under achieving as far as as far
as that --
So I just want to thank you for
sharing your perspective as far
as the the fact that seven one I
appreciate your respect as well
just one comment it's it's a big
interested.
Of the legislature as far as the
faculty in diverse you know you
you mentioned that.
We teach I could see.
Baby boomers retiring and as we
as a replace these --
These positions it's really
important that we we work hard
to try to have people that
reflect the students not just
it's morally right but in a
research shows that students.
Do better when they have faculty
members that reflect the
community so.
That set a top priority of I
know that is chairman Mr team
this is one of his top higher
and priorities and we've been
working on this for the last few
years.
Continue do so.
That is that's definitely a
priority for us state that peak
issue for us there is one the
the size of the pipeline off --
You know graduate students PhD
students who are ready to take
faculty positions.
And the tremendous competition
with with other distributions --
And for the pipeline I'm getting
back to graduate students if we
you know fund --
Graduate students PhD students
that around the state UC has has
been the pipeline so the more
you know diverse students and
graduate students weekend.
The more be built the pipeline.
In of the faculty positions it's
it's really tough.
On my own department economics
here --
Actually benefitted from the you
know state funding for faculty
diversity that --
Was provided to us a year ago.
We we competed for that for the
first year we didn't get it and
do you think campus actually
provided funds on their own
resources to support as a little
bit.
And last year we got --
Got funding add that that helped
us we also hand and you know in
don't cheer an awful cheers to
one of those for for fundraising.
At now --
Experiences being we have
scrounging around we have for
look at all the further north
told year old enough every
single person and trying to see
if that person must move all
what it would take to move the
person -- We
did that three years ago scanned
entire market --
You know made made an offer I
think made to offers but all we
did was raise their salaries at
their home institution recession
as we're making an offer their
family back and counter offer.
That's the reality --
Last year we were we were more
successful --
We got for the state funding we
got -- One
M. Hispanic school young can
attrition --
Who got --
First of that apple stock for a
year which expenses at his
tenure clock --
Witness the state funding and
then he's he's --
On board as a faculty member --
Me also hired if it female
faculty member --
That for that --
With with that supports and went
all out and then in the process --
In turn funds to get some seek
funding for a center and that's
the kind of support that it
takes to hire minority faculty
diversifying. Eight in the tree
stream a competitive market yeah
we had a three hour hearing on
this. Three weeks ago so --
We we we we know it's it's that
it is complicated but was the
one that.
You know make it a priority
summer we're we're clear
committed to doing that we are
fully committed to doing that.
Thank you aye a pre shape the
perspective they appreciate the
advocacy certainly I started as
a student activists at the UC.
And my college friends don't
understand how I ended up
working for the UC for eleven
years -- The
and that is so I appreciate the
role and a think as chair
McCarty said at Daddy's your
role to be advocates in to be a
vocal about --
You know the issues and
imperfections we see in the
system.
There was a comment made around
decrease if not a de funding and
support to and documented
students and I'm hoping that
someone could please clarify.
What that means --
And I don't.
Is there a program that went
away was that from cut coming
from you see office of the
president.
I can provide and I don't think
we can ask the the in the UC
office the president that
represented here maybe they can
might not.
Thank you term McCarty say ever
attended university of
California office of the
president --
We currently have funding from
documents student programs for
eighteen nineteen that husband.
That was set as a three year
funding that ends in eighteen
nineteen that has not yet been
extended because it's funded out
of the UC --
Piece budget.
The region to any written up OP
budget around may of twenty
nineteen so this coming spring.
Would be when the region's
approved the potential
extensions but we haven't
unfunded anything.
It's just we haven't yet.
Actively approved the next cycle
of funding.
That's done by the region's that
is done by the region discerning
indication that that's going to
be a problem going forward.
The regions are highly
supportive of undocumented
students okay services.
Thank you for the flag it for
and so on the record we support
that.
And I know the regions that are
urging have have look to look at
other pots of money you see why
to prioritize.
Statewide priorities and and
this is one that we have with
that.
That talked about so.
Okay thank you okay.
Thank you for that for the
presentation I believe we we now
have the opportunity if anybody.
In your three hours now but if
anybody.
Would like to speak --
Is our public comment sections
of there is anybody.
Please --
Plan F. right here.
I'm reading a prepared statement
greater everybody my name's
Johnson good for those who don't
know me.
I service vice president the
board of trustees for some of
the City College but I'm here
representing the re claim
California hard to cation
coalition which is.
A coalition of unions fact two
groups and student groups across
all three segments marvelous
comments I think.
Yeah I was a student leader they
get better every year self at
this their GPAs are rising but
that because he's I think rising
even more --
So first I want to say thank you
for hosting I think it's very
interesting to do a deep dive on
a campus specific instead of on
the system why because you know
each campus is different --
I want to thank you all for what
you've done to find higher
education the state of
California thing you know you
three specifically have been
very strong advocates.
And yeah I think we all believe
that.
A higher education is the single
best social mobilize are
available to us as a society to
move people up. Six years ago
the state fully funded the
university and there was no
tuition.
With only incidental fees.
Today individual students and
families are being given the
responsibility of funding the
university rather than the
public at large at UCSB were
saying it's at a two to one
ratio the system wide COR funds
are about almost.
Fifty fifty coming from of the
state or from tuition.
On top of that.
They're paying more while
receiving less per student
funding been compared to the
year two thousand in the year.
Nineteen eighty five while seats
are you know being allocated to
tied to state students to help
make up for those budget
shortfalls.
Further this overall reduction
state support happened gradually
ask camps did become less white
and more diverse and as our
prison populations grew and
funding was diverted in that
direction.
The result has been an
unprecedented to because even if
you get a cal grant to pay for
your entire tuition which I did
not be tuition for four years.
I still ended up with twenty
thousand dollars in debt because
you need to pay for the cost of
living still.
And it's difficult even measure
how many people are self
selected out of the system
because they were data verse or
that they were shocked by the
sticker price as was mentioned --
Even if you know your come from
alone can background I did.
A lot of my friends in end up
going because it costs too much
wasn't for them.
It's often said that it's way
too expensive to return to
tuition free college or to
restore quality in person
funding.
Or to expand access in fully
fund each new student into the
university or to provide robust
financial aid for cost of living
expenses. To do them all would
seem you know impossible.
We are here to say that it will
actually cost fifteen million
dollars if you include the six
billion required for pop ninety
eight you know fall new revenue.
I which translates 250% of
taxpayers paying a tax of sixty
six dollars a year or less --
To find this. To fund this
budget at that rate [inaudible]
90%. One money send.
The without.
To restoring per student funding.
Repurpose in financial aid to
cover costs of living expenses.
And to expand seats available.
We're also looking at metrics to
correspond with that such a
large increase in public funding.
But all could be done for a
relatively affordable price to
the individual and a tax form of
financing inside of a tuition
former financing which you know
we we feel that tuition is in
fact.
A tax on those who choose to go
to college.
This would be a line the
university back into becoming a
true public good rather than
individual endeavor.
This would and this in depth
that crisis along Badgett its
graduates all of them not just
the rich ones to start their
lives after college without that
because right now.
Most of us graduate with that --
And then we will be able to
spend our money in the local
economy instead of sending it to
Pennsylvania which is where my
three hundred dollars a month
goes -- We
went up and down the state the
past two years as the coalition
raising awareness building
support and taking feedback on
our idea and plan.
And we have found resounding
support.
From organizations of all kinds.
We look for our coalition goal
is to finalize the bill a place
holder and first week of January
for introduction in the next
session.
That encompasses the tenants
I've described we look forward
to working with this committee
the Senate and other partners in
the coming months to reclaim the
promise of the master plan.
Set in nineteen sixty rate in in
one year on a typewriter --
For the twenty first century now
moving forward.
We want to end by saying that in
the last session the legislature
and the governor.
You know accumulated the votes
and passed the gas tax.
Like that to address a dire need
that I I do support that and we
do support that.
Are we prepared to do the same
for the dire need in higher
education right now.
Thank you [inaudible]
Thank you.
Okay thing nobody else.
That --
Asking clues are hearing this
afternoon thanks again to the
participants and thank you to
the UC Santa Barbara
[inaudible]
Thank you